Ja, herzlich willkommen zur Alternativlos, die Folge numero... 46. 46, mal wieder eine Corona-Sondersendung. Wir werden heute das Format mal ein bisschen anders machen. Wir haben zwei Gäste. Die erste ist Christiane Hütter. Hallo, Christiane.
Hallo.
Ihr werdet bemerken, dass wir dieses Mal vielleicht so ein bisschen anders sind, weil wir remote recorden, um das mit der Distanz irgendwie auf die Reihe zu kriegen, haben wir uns über Studio Link zusammenkonektiert, was so möglicherweise gewisse kleine Probleme hat, über die wir dann aber...
Um den Bußgel dann aus dem Weg zu gehen.
Um den Bußgel aus dem Weg zu gehen.
Die Berlin jetzt ausgeschrieben hat für Leute, die sich trotzdem treffen, ohne triftigen Grund. Und ein Podcast zur Beruhigung der Menschen zählt leider nicht als triftiger Grund.
Wie, ihr habt mir gesagt, wir wollen die Menschen beruhigen?
Ja, zumindest in der ersten Hälfte.
Genau, kurze Vorstellung, Christiane.
Also dann hättet ihr doch alleine aufnehmen müssen, weil zu zweit wäre es ja gegangen.
Stimmt. Christiane, stell dich doch mal kurz vor, vielleicht selber.
Ja, ich bin Christiane Hütter. Ich bin Autorin, Künstlerin und aber auch Diplompsychologin und hab mich vor einigen Jahren mit Katastrophen beschäftigt bzw. mit Großschadenslagen und was diese für psychologische Auswirkungen haben können. Und deshalb habt ihr mich gefragt, ob ich irgendwie heute dazu komme und mich mit euch darüber unterhalte.
Ja, so ein Zufall, das passt gerade gut.
Christiane hat auch mit mir zusammen das Podiplotbuch, worüber wir in der letzten Sendung kurz geredet haben, geschrieben. Also falls ihr irgendwie Zeit zum Lesen habt jetzt gerade, dann sei es noch mal empfohlen, gefährliche Menschen, wir tun den Link nochmal in die Show notes. Ja, was da draußen gerade so passiert, so dieser Ausnahmezustand, der bleibt ja nicht so ganz ohne Folgen. So wir sitzen jetzt irgendwie alle zu Hause rum, trauen uns manchmal kurz raus in den Park, um noch irgendwie uns ein bisschen zu bewegen, um nicht total durchzudrehen. Was ist sowas irgendwie erforscht? Also gibt es darüber irgendwie Wissenschaft, was das mit den Menschen macht?
Ich glaube in dieser Form, wie wir das aktuell erleben, ist das nicht erforscht. Da gibt es im Moment Forschungen, die anfangen. Es gibt irgendwie eine Psychologin, die eine Forschung zum Thema Einsamkeit jetzt gestartet hat zum Beispiel. Aber was so diese Art von Isolation, die ja so sehr flächendeckend ist, also es sind ja viele Millionen, wenn nicht Milliarden von Menschen, die gerade weltweit davon betroffen sind, dass sie in ihrer Bewegung eingeschränkt sind, das ist nicht erforscht. Also man kann natürlich gucken, wo gibt es etwas Ähnliches, halt irgendwie, wo nicht so viele gleichzeitig betroffen sind, wo gibt es vielleicht auch etwas Ähnliches, dass Ereignisse eintreten, die man so nicht antizipieren konnte. Die Lage ist allerdings so, also wirklich sehr komplex, weil das ist ja jetzt auch kein Ereignis, das irgendwie eingetreten ist und bumm, alles ist dann irgendwie anders. Eine Naturkatastrophe oder der Beginn eines Krieges oder Ähnliches. Es ist ja so ein bisschen ein langsamerer Prozess irgendwie, so ein langsamerer Prozess. Man hat das Gefühl, irgendetwas verändert sich ganz krass. Alle wissen, dass es jetzt doch länger dauert und nicht so schnell wieder weggeht, wie man es vielleicht am Anfang noch dachte.
Wie ist denn das andersrum?
Ja, es ist eine sehr komplexe Situation.
Es gab ja schon die ersten Leute, die gesagt haben, es wird eine große Scheidungswelle auf uns zurollen, weil die Leute gerade eben nicht alleine zu Hause sitzen, sondern so mit der ganzen Familie und dass da die Leute irgendwie Koller kriegen. Und es gab auch die, ich will nicht sagen Ansage, aber so die Befürchtung, dass die Fälle von häuslicher Gewalt nach oben gehen werden. Und so ist das erforscht oder ist man da auch eher blind?
Da guckt man natürlich im Moment so ein bisschen, was da aktuell schon passiert. Und da sieht man die Zahlen gehen nach oben. Das ist natürlich auch eine große Angst. Und so etwas wie häusliche Gewalt zu erforschen, ist ja generell sehr schwierig, da überhaupt an Zahlen zu kommen. Aber natürlich ist es gerade auch eine große Gefahr, wenn zum Beispiel auch gleichzeitig viele Frauenhäuser nicht wie üblich einfach offene Türen haben und man einfach hingehen kann, sondern da auch virusbedingt die Prozesse ein bisschen anders sind. Und das ist zum Beispiel in Frankreich gerade ganz interessant, weil es da halt irgendwie wirklich breit angelegte Kampagnen gibt, dass man in die Apotheke gehen kann, ein bestimmtes Stichwort sagen kann und dann irgendwie als betroffene Frau sehr einfach Hilfe bekommen kann. Einfach weil sie halt versuchen möchten, da irgendwie die Brücken so breit und so leicht zugänglich wie möglich zu bauen. Belastbare Zahlen gibt es aber auch da, glaube ich, noch nicht.
Und was mich ja persönlich so ein bisschen fertig macht, ist ja dieses Wir schränken unsere Grundechte ja gerade ziemlich dramatisch ein, so was ja nach dem Infektionsschutzgesetz auch gar eine rechtliche Grundlage hat. Und es gibt so diese Lippenbekenntnisse der Politik, dass es halt irgendwie nur alles von temporärer Dauer sein soll. Aber niemand hat irgendwie eine Idee, wie das wieder zurückgerollt werden soll oder wer dann die Verantwortung übernimmt, das zurückzurollen und aus welchen Gründen. Und das ist eigentlich so mehr was, was mich halt persönlich halt irgendwie so ein bisschen irgendwie anfrisst. So wenn ich jetzt wüsste, okay das sind jetzt zwei Wochen oder drei Wochen und wir halten es jetzt irgendwie zusammen durch so und dann ist halt Schluss und dann ist irgendwie alles wieder gut, dann würde es ja irgendwie gehen. Aber so mit dieser, diesem offenen Ende, so dieser, dieser kompletten Ungewissheit irgendwie, merke ich schon, dass es irgendwie total nagt.
Na und die Geschwindigkeit, mit der das Backup geht, ist ja auch relativ hoch. Ja, also ich habe ja neulich im Blog dazu was geschrieben. Mir ist nämlich aufgefallen, so bei all den Maßnahmen, die es da jetzt gab, wo ja richtig krasse Sachen dabei waren, wie Aufhebung des Demonstrationsrechtes. Die Sache, über die Leute gemeckert haben, war die Handydaten. Und der Rest war im Grunde okay. Nicht nur okay, sondern die Leute haben gesagt, ja, jetzt endlich. Also die, wie soll ich sagen, die Leichtigkeit, mit der die Leute dann sofort ihre Meinung geändert haben und plötzlich dafür sind, dass der Staat ein bisschen härter zugreift, ist schon ziemlich beeindruckend, finde ich, weil es eben zeigt, dass es mal leicht irgendwie von Gutrechten und so weiter zu reden. Aber in Situationen der Krise wünschen sich die Leute halt irgendwie einen starken Staat herbei. Oder was weiß ich, vielleicht ist das psychologisch die Vaterfigur, die jetzt hier für Ordnung sorgt, also keine Ahnung, was denn die Mechanismen sind. Aber es ist halt schon beobachtbar, dass die Einstellung zu Grundrechtseinschränkungen sich deutlich ändert, wenn man in so einer Angstsituation ist.
Total, und das ist natürlich sehr gruselig. Ich weiß nicht, ob es unbedingt die Vaterfigur sein muss. Ich glaube, vielleicht ist das auch irgendwie so eine generelle Überforderung, weil im Moment gibt es ja nicht den einen Experten, der uns irgendwie sagen kann, so und so wird es. Und das braucht so und so viele Wochen. Und dann ist alles wieder gut. Oder dann ist alles eben nicht wieder gut. Also so wäre es, wenn die Situation einfach nur kompliziert wäre und wie eine Maschine funktionieren würde, die man irgendwie, wenn man sich mal reinfuchst, verstehen und erklären kann. Aber so ist es ja nicht, weil es von vielen unterschiedlichen Faktoren abhängt und teilweise ja währenddessen jetzt noch erforscht wird bzw. bekämpft wird. Aber ich glaube, so dieser Wunsch nach einer starken Ansage ist natürlich auch ganz stark der Wunsch danach, dass es eben doch jemanden gibt, der es versteht und der es verändern kann. Ich glaube, das erklärt zum Beispiel auch, wieso dieser Drosten-Podcast so wahnsinnig erfolgreich ist. Abgesehen davon, dass er natürlich auch irgendwie informativ ist und dass es auch ganz gut tut, irgendwie das jeden Tag in seiner Tagesstruktur zu haben und da mal reinzuhören, hat er natürlich jetzt noch irgendwie so eine ganz andere Rolle, die auch irgendwie so eine komische Art von Vergemeinschaftung fast schafft. Also, dass man sich darüber unterhalten kann, wie sich Leute vor 20 Jahren über den Sonntagstatort unterhalten haben oder so. Es ist plötzlich so ein verbindendes Medium und ein verbindender Experte, der dann natürlich wieder auch ganz viel Unmut abkriegen kann an anderen Stellen.
Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen mehr als das, oder? Ich habe den Eindruck, es gibt ein bisschen einen Erwachsenen im Raum, der sich kümmert. Also, es ist nicht nur, wir haben was über das, wir reden können, sondern es gibt jemanden, der sich kümmert.
Es gibt jemanden, der sich kümmert, wenn es nicht sogar jemanden gibt, der irgendwie fast so eine sekular-religiöse Erlöserrolle einnimmt oder irgendwie so ein Prediger ist, an dem natürlich ganz viel Hoffnung hängt. Also, ich finde, es geht fast darüber hinaus, dass da jemand ist, der uns irgendwie Fakten liefert.
Na, er schafft halt eine Konsensrealität. Das ist zumindest so ein Ding, die Rolle, die früher die Tagesschau oder im Osten die aktuelle Kamera hatte. Die Realität, auf die sich alle beziehen können, der Informationsstand, den irgendwie alle, die daran teilnehmen, teilen können. Und den man dann als Konsensrealität halt irgendwie als Bezugspunkt nehmen kann.
Es gab da auch einen super interessanten Effekt, fand ich, dass der Drosten halt ein Wissenschaftler ist. Das heißt, der tut nicht so, als wenn er Sachen weiß, sondern sagt dann halt, das wissen wir noch nicht. Und die Politik hat so eine Woche ungefähr gebraucht, bis sie verstanden hat, dass das ankommt. Vorher waren alle, ja, ja, das ist jetzt irgendwie, bis dann und dann haben wir das geklärt. Aber so eine Woche, nachdem der Drosten anfing, seine Unwägbarkeiten in das Narrativ einzuflechten, hat die Politik auch angefangen. Und jetzt ist auch in der Politik, ja, wir wissen nicht, wie lange das dauern wird. Aber es gab so eine Woche lang eine Übergangsphase, wo die ganzen, ich würde mal sagen, die Blender aus der Politik weiterhin simuliert haben, sie wüssten, wie das jetzt weitergeht. Oder haben es klein oder groß zu reden versucht, je nach Agenda. Aber das ist ja jetzt weg. Jetzt heißt es, okay, diese Maßnahme gilt bis dann und dann, aber die werden wir halt verlängern, wenn es nötig ist. Also, was man als seriös empfindet als Zuhörer am Fernsehen, hat sich auch komplett geändert. So, das ist jetzt halt nicht mehr jemand, der so tut, als hätte er die Fakten in der Hand.
Also, dieses Phänomen, dass die Informationslage total unklar ist, ist ja eigentlich bei so Katastrophen jetzt nicht so selten, oder?
Nee, eigentlich ist das ja meistens so. Es ist, glaube ich, jetzt so eine Phase, wo das extrem lange dauert bzw. sich lange hinzieht. Aber ansonsten ist es ja fast so, dass über Katastrophen irgendwie fast schon in so einer Art eigenem News-Genre berichtet wird. Also, es gibt zum Beispiel Studien, die das irgendwie sogar das Nachrichtenmodell des Katastrophischen nennen, wo natürlich irgendwie Krisen auch so ein bisschen das Tagesgeschäft überhaupt strukturieren und dann in gewisser Weise auch eingeplant werden. Damit man etwas hat, worüber man berichten kann. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch so Konventionen, wie darüber berichtet wird, auch wenn Unsicherheit vorhanden ist. Wo man in der Berichterstattung dann auch sehen kann, es gibt da so bestimmte Elemente, die irgendwie vorkommen. Es gibt bestimmte Dramatogien, die da benutzt werden, etc. Und das ist natürlich was, was jetzt in diesem Fall, wo irgendwie die Informationslage sich vielleicht nach einer Woche noch mal ändert, dann auch relativ leicht durchschaubar ist, dass das vielleicht irgendwie nicht so die richtige Berichterstattung oder nicht so die richtige Deutung erstmal war.
Also mir ging es eher um die Reaktion der Politik als um die Berichterstattung der Presse. Da können wir auch darüber reden. Da habe ich nämlich auch ein paar Sachen beobachtet. Aber mein Eindruck war, dass so insbesondere demokratischen Staaten nicht so lange durchgehalten haben wie so die Halb- oder Ganzdiktaturen, wo die politischen Führer viel Wert drauf gelegt haben, so zu tun, als sei überhaupt kein Problem. Also man konnte so in Russland und China, konnte man ganz gut sehen, so hier Problem gibt es nicht. Oder Türkei. Aber die sind ja auch irgendwann ungeschwenkt, die meisten jedenfalls. Und in Deutschland gab es halt diese Woche ungefähr, zwischen so wir tun so, als hätten wir die Antworten, und okay, wir wissen es alles nicht. Also auch tatsächlich frei herauszugeben, weil ich glaube, man analysiert hat, dass die Leute das hören wollen. Die Leute wollen jetzt kein Bullshit hören, sondern die möchten jetzt gern, wenn nicht klar ist, möchten sie das gerne hören. Also es ist ja, ich weiß nicht, man kann ja vielleicht sagen, es ist eher so Aufgabe der Kirche zu sagen, seelsorgemäßig, ja ja, das wird alles wieder gut. Und das ist sicher eine Sache, die man auch von der Politik hören will. Aber man möchte auch, wenn da noch ein Problem kommt, möchte man das auch bitte rechtzeitig hören, damit man sich so ein bisschen drauf einstellen kann. Und das hat so eine Woche über gegeben, fand ich. Und jetzt ist die Politik halt voll auf der Linie. Ja, wissen wir auch nicht, machen wir dann halt.
Ja, wobei ich finde, auch da gibt es so Veränderungen. Ich fand zum Beispiel die Rede von Merkel, fand ich ganz gut, weil sie das da auch sehr deutlich gemacht hat, dass diese Maßnahmen jetzt irgendwie erst mal halt getroffen werden müssen und dass noch nicht klar ist, wie es dann weitergeht. Und dass das aber natürlich zeitnah beobachtet wird, um auch angemessen darauf reagieren zu können. Das war halt irgendwie halt so eine offizielle Verkündung dessen und hat gut funktioniert, hat sich gut vermittelt, finde ich. Während jetzt irgendwie dieser weitere Wechsel, diese Verlängerung, dass die Maßnahmen erst mal bis zum 20. nicht aufgehoben werden, sich irgendwie so eingeschlichen hat. Ich glaube, irgendjemand, ich habe vergessen, wer es war, hat es in einer Pressemeldung gesagt. Und dann war es plötzlich eine Information, die da war.
Ja, das war einfach vier Wochen. Also ich habe ja Mails gekriegt von so Verschwörungsleuten, die meinten, ha ha, 20. April ist doch der Geburtstag des Führers. Nach dem Motto, irgendwie, das ist hier eine geheime Botschaft der AfD. Natürlich Unsinn, das war einfach vier Wochen in der Zukunft. Aber so, ich fand es schon mal unter uns, alles, was die Merkel da gesagt hat, hätte man sich auch sparen können. Nichts davon war jetzt irgendwie, ja, natürlich, das weiß ich ja, dass die Merkel auch nicht weiß. Ja, und dass die Maßnahmen halt beobachtet werden. Dann guckt man, ob sie tun, das ist auch wichtig. Aber dass man das ausspricht, hat ja trotzdem eine Funktion erfüllt. Und darauf wollte ich so ein bisschen hinaus, dass es jetzt plötzlich wichtiger ist, zu sagen, okay, wir kümmern uns. Und wir wissen auch nicht, aber wir kümmern uns. Wir haben verstanden, dass es ein Problem ist, als zu sagen, ja, ja, wird bearbeitet. Bei allen anderen Problemen ist es ja immer noch so, ich sag mal, Pkw-Maut oder BER, da ist ja immer noch, ja, ja. Weil so bei dieser Krankheit ist es jetzt andersrum bei der Pandemie. Da ist jetzt die Botschaft, die die Leute hören wollen, okay, wir haben verstanden, dass es ein Problem ist. War mein Eindruck.
Wobei, also ich glaube, dieses politische Ansagen machen, da gibt es ja irgendwie auch mehrere Flavors von. Also einmal so Söder, der halt irgendwie versucht, halt irgendwie den starken Mann und die, die irgendwie, wir kümmern uns drum, Figur zu verkörpern. Und dann eher so Merkel, die halt mit so, ich bin bei euch als irgendwie Landesmutter und wir werden das schon irgendwie durchstehend zusammen macht. So, das halt ja irgendwie, sind ja schon durchaus unterschiedliche Ansprachen von psychologischen Bedürfnissen, oder?
Auf jeden Fall, klar. Also es gab ja zum Beispiel auch, das fand ich auch ganz interessant, bevor die Maßnahmen beschlossen worden sind, gab es ja auch so ziemlich lauthörbare Rufe nach Ausgangssperre. Und das ist natürlich was, was dann irgendwie dadurch befriedigt wird. Und ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, dadurch, dass sich die Welt gerade so schnell verändert, überfordert das irgendwie die Verarbeitungskapazität und auch Geschwindigkeit der allermeisten Menschen, wenn nicht sogar aller, total. Wir merken nur, dass irgendetwas gerade zu Ende ist und vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr wiederkommt. Und das führt natürlich auch zu unterschiedlichen Phasen, in denen man dann sein kann irgendwie. Das ist ja fast wie so eine Ablösung von... Ja, das ist fast wie, wenn jemand stirbt oder so. Also, dass es so verschiedene Arten gibt, damit umzugehen, oder verschiedene Strategien, die sich abwechseln irgendwie, von nicht wahrhaben wollen über Zorn und Aggression und Schuldzuweisungen, darüber, dass man versucht, mit dem Schicksal zu verhandeln oder depressiv wird und sich irgendwann dann doch fügt. Diese Phasen haben natürlich auch unterschiedliche Bedürfnisse. Und die werden dann natürlich von unterschiedlichen, ich sag jetzt mal Politiker, Innentypen auch unterschiedlich bedient.
Klar. Sind diese Phasen, also wenn man jetzt sozusagen das Ganze mal framed als Abschied von einer Welt, die nicht wiederkommt, passiert das synchron bei den Menschen? Oder ist das irgendwie eher so ein relativ asynchroner Prozess, wo alle in erstmal sehr unterschiedlichen Phasen rumhängen?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das synchron passiert, weil sich diese Phasen ja auch bei der einzelnen Person irgendwie auch abwechseln können, in unterschiedlich langen Zeitabständen. Also wenn ich sogar irgendwie im Laufe eines einzelnen Tages, dass sich das irgendwie verändert. Und ich glaube, das merkt man auch gerade, dass gerade auch durch diesen Effekt, dass etwas passiert und dass aber eigentlich alle gerade so für sich sein müssen, zwangsweise, dass da natürlich auch irgendwie so ein bestimmtes Ventil fehlt. Also normalerweise, wenn irgendwie so weitreichende Geschehnisse irgendwie stattfinden, ist er irgendwie so ein menschlicher Impuls, dass man sich irgendwie zusammentut und dass man irgendwie so, was weiß ich, so echte Gemeinschaft sucht und sich irgendwie abends in die Bar setzt und irgendwie darüber austauscht. Weil egal, wie schlimm es ist, das hilft ja irgendwie ein bisschen. Und das geht im Moment ja nur total begrenzt. Und das ist natürlich auch noch was, was dazukommt irgendwie so ein bisschen als so eine unbekannte Komponente. Was macht das eigentlich? Und was macht dieses alleine Zuhause sein oder dieses irgendwie mit der vielleicht dysfunktionalen Familie Zuhause sein? Was gibt das eigentlich noch auf diese generelle Unsicherheit, die Menschen haben, noch hinzu?
Das heißt also, diese Phasen, von denen du sprachst, die quasi diese typischen Verarbeitungsphasen sind, die sind eigentlich nur so quasi Kategorien oder Schubladen, aber jetzt irgendwie keinen Ablauf, also keine Ordnung, in der die zwangsläufig vorkommen?
Nee, nicht unbedingt. Also diese Phasen, das sind im Grunde wirklich so die Sterbephasen nach Kübler-Ross, die auch im klassischen Sterbeprozess nicht unbedingt in dieser Reihenfolge auftauchen müssen. Also es ist nicht so, dass sie aufeinander folgen. Ich meine, also die letzte Phase, dass man irgendwie zustimmt und irgendwie sich so seinem Schicksal ergibt und irgendwie einfach einseht, wir kommen jetzt hier so vielleicht nicht weiter, es ist vielleicht jetzt vorbei und wir müssen uns irgendwie darin einrichten. Das ist meistens die, die am Schluss kommt, natürlich, wenn man Glück hat.
Das finde ich aber eine interessante Frage, weil mir drängt sich der Eindruck auf, dass wir die Rollen der Politik aus so ein bisschen in dieselben Kategorien teilen können. Also in der Denial-Phase brauchst du jemanden wie den Drosten, der dir erklärt hat, hier sind die Fakten, guck mal, ist ein Problem. So und dann, wenn du anfängst zu sagen, okay, Anger, dann brauchst du jemanden, der sagt, pass auf, wir managen das. So ein Söder-Typ. Und wenn du irgendwie traurig wirst, weil das ist alles hier am Ende, brauchst du jemanden wie die Merkel, der irgendwie sagt, ja, pass auf, hier ist alles gut. Genau. Es war eine lustige Idee, dass wir Politiker-Typen für die verschiedenen Phasen haben. Das gefällt mir, der Gedanke.
Klingt jetzt nicht völlig absurd. Also natürlich klingt es total absurd.
Na ja, man kann dazu ja auch noch sagen, Politikerinnen sind ja auch Menschen, die vielleicht auch in ihren eigenen Phasen irgendwie sind. Oder ich finde, man sieht zum Beispiel auch mal, ich finde, man kann diese Phasen sogar noch auf einzelne Länder übertragen. Oder auf, das weiß ich, wenn man anguckt, was ist Bolsonaro eigentlich? Der ist, glaube ich, nicht in der Zustimmungsphase.
Nee, der ist noch klar und denial eigentlich. Gut, und der ist ein Spinner. Ja, wollen wir noch kurz über die Medien reden, bevor wir dazu kommen, was wir jetzt eigentlich machen und wie man damit umgehen kann?
Ich glaube, es ist total egal, wie man damit umgehen kann, weil die alle auch ein Ticker-Format umgestellt haben, was mir überhaupt nicht hilft bei der Sortierung der Fakten. Sondern es ist einfach so ein, weiß ich nicht, irgendwie. Also erstens, wenn du irgendjemandem was zeigen willst, dann steht da schon was anderes unter der URL wieder, wenn der dann da klickt. Und die Einordnung und die Fakten sind auch total gemixt. Also diese Ticker sind ja irgendwie populär geworden mit Fußballspielen, glaube ich. Das war so das erste, wo ich das gesehen habe, wo die dann halt irgendwie.
Ich dachte bei Armag Läufen.
Ja genau, Armag Läufe. So, aber das haben wir jetzt als Dauerzustand. So die Tagesschau, Spiegel, Guardian, die haben einfach nur noch den Corona-Ticker und irgendwie so ein paar andere Sachen, die halt keine Rolle spielen. So das finde ich eigentlich total furchtbar, weil die Presse eben nicht nur die Aufgabe hat, mir irgendwie einen Ticker zu geben, sondern ich möchte auch eine Einordnung haben. Und ich möchte das auch ein bisschen sortiert haben, damit ich sie an so etwas habe ich dann verpasst. Aber das geht halt im Moment gar nicht, sondern muss ich alle Ticker von vorne bis hinten lesen, bis mir etwas bekannt vorkommt. Das ist so ein bisschen, finde ich, ist wie so, als wenn die abdanken und sagen, pass auf, ich habe jetzt keinen Bock mehr, das kann jetzt hier die Software machen. So wirkt das auf mich.
Naja, vielleicht ist da auch niemand mehr.
Die haben mich auch gerade gedacht, vielleicht.
Die KI macht den Ticker.
Aber ich finde es auch wirklich total krass, wie unterschiedlich so die Kategorien von Nachrichten sind, die dann in so einem Ticker drin stehen. Also das ist nicht mehr so Äpfel mit Birnen mischen, sondern irgendwie so ein Obstkorb. Und da ist aber auch noch ein bisschen Gemüse und Schokolade drin. Weil manchmal sind es dann so ganz große relevante Sachen und dann aber irgendwie so was Kleines, was vielleicht irgendwie skurril und lustig ist.
Der Bürgermeister von Großburg-Wedel hat gesagt so, und ich so, äh, äh, äh.
Ja genau, das macht einen wahnsinnig.
Also meine Lieblingsmeldung gestern war die eine AP-Meldung, also eine richtige Nachrichtenticker-Meldung über einen abgebrannten LKW voller Klopapier irgendwo in Texas.
Hör mal, das musst du doch wissen. Das ist doch wichtig für deine persönliche Lebensverschreibung.
Ich dachte mir so, genau, wenn du in Texas in dieser Ecke wohnst, sicherlich, aber auf dem weltweiten Epitica fand ich es ein bisschen übertrieben. Also gut, ich meine, das haben sie dann irgendwann umsortiert in die Audities-Kategorie. Also was halt irgendwie ihr, quasi ihr Panorama ist, aber trotzdem fand ich es schon ein bisschen schräg.
Naja, aber es geht ja nicht nur um so Meldungen, sondern wir haben auch so Fake-Meldungen. Also beim Guardian ist irgendwie jeden Tag eine Zahl, so und so viele Tote gibt oder so und so viele Infizite. Das ist wie so ein, als wenn da irgendwie Sportbetten drauf stünden. Ja, kommt mir das vor, so das betrifft mich doch überhaupt nicht. Und die Zahl geht nach oben, ja, das wusste ich vorher. Ich wusste sogar, wie schnell sie nach oben gehen wird. Ja, weil irgendwie ist halt Exponentialfunktion. Aber so, das ist wie so irgendwie, als wenn gleich einer aufsteht und Bingo ruft, finde ich total ab. Ja, da und da gab es Todesfälle, hier gibt es Todesfälle. Ja, ist bekannt und jetzt, so wichtig ist, was machen wir jetzt?
Na, die einzig relevante Nachricht, die einzig relevante Nachricht wäre halt die Abweichung von der Exponentialfunktion.
Ja, inklusive Einordnung. So, warum glauben wir denn, dass das abweicht? Jetzt haben wir gerade 50.000 Tote überschritten, sagt Tagesschau, okay und jetzt, was mache ich jetzt? So, total wertvoll ist die, die Meldung. So, ja und?
Es wird halt auch so inflationär, diese Zahlen zu hören, so, das ist eigentlich das Krasse, dass man natürlich auch irgendwie so ein bisschen abstumpft dabei, von Tag zu Tag.
Ja klar. Also es erinnert mich total irgendwie an diese Költe Krieg, Atomkriegsberechnung, also wo halt man immer nur so in Megatoten gerechnet hat, was halt so völlig unvorstellbare Dimensionen sind, die halt auf der anderen Seite dann halt irgendwie, also es gibt halt nichts dazwischen, also es gibt halt irgendwie nur so die zehntausenden Toten und dann halt so die viel zu nahe dran Betroffenheitsberichterstattung, die ich mittlerweile überhaupt nicht mehr sehen und hören kann. Also ich denke so, ja, warum, wozu, was ist das jetzt gerade für ein Mehrwert, so schön, liebe Journalisten, dass ihr jetzt irgendwie noch irgendwie arbeitet, aber vielleicht können wir auch nochmal über irgendwas anderes reden, als irgendwie darüber, wie schlecht es irgendjemand geht, dem man natürlich leid tut und wo ich es auch irgendwie gut finde, dass irgendwie die Person gehört wird, nur vielleicht halt nicht irgendwie in weltweiten kuratierten Medien, sondern da kann er irgendwie Facebook oder Twitter oder was auch immer für einen nehmen und sich da irgendwie Gleichgesinnte suchen und vielleicht sogar Menschen, die ihm helfen, so oder ihr. Das ist halt irgendwie so ein Ding, wo ich halt irgendwie so ein bisschen, gerade auch am Hack am zweifeln bin, dass die Medien noch irgendeine Ahnung haben, was sie da tun und was sie da, also was jetzt eigentlich ihre Aufgabe dabei wäre, bei dem ganzen Spiel.
Also ich habe da schon Mitleid mit denen. Aber ich habe mich zum Beispiel sehr geärgert, als es losging und dann wirklich jede Zeitung irgendein Feature hatte, wo einer ihrer Angestellten versucht hat, beim Senat irgendwie einen Test zu kriegen. Und dann seitenlang, ja das ging nicht. Und dann dachte ich so, ja ist ja schön, dass ihr das alle gemerkt habt. Was machen wir denn jetzt, ist doch die interessante Frage. Das habe ich jetzt schon so. Und die nächste Welle war, dass alle versucht haben, sich für die Künstlerhilfe einzutragen und einen Tag warten mussten. Und ich dachte ja auch so, ja ist ja gut. Ja, dass die Maßnahmen alle nicht sofort funktionieren, ist doch klar, bei so Panik irgendwie sofort Hilfe zu finden. Das finde ich dann auch nicht weiterhelfend, dazu berichten, wie schlimm alles ist. So mir fehlt halt der Fokus darauf, was wir jetzt machen. Und bei den Zahlen ist es nicht nur eine Abstufung, sondern es ist auch eine Umwandlung des Problems von einem Konkreten in ein abstraktes Problem. Denn sobald da irgendwie 5 Nullen stehen, ist es nichts mehr, was mich betrifft. Sondern es ist eher so wie ein Vogelschwarm der Größe ist gesichtet worden. Das ist keine fastbare Größe mehr für mich. Und das ist nicht nur bei den Infizierten und Toten, sondern insbesondere bei allen Maßnahmen und die Wirtschaft zu regulieren. Da werden welche Milliardenbeträge hin und her geworfen. Und das mag ja sein, dass das ein Informationswert hat, aber es ändert nichts für mich. Ich hätte gerne mehr Fokus darauf, was kann ich denn jetzt tun oder was kann die Regierung jetzt tun? Überhaupt mal ein paar Optionen auf den Tisch legen. So weg von diesem irgendwie, das gibt überhaupt nur noch eine Sache, die wir jetzt machen können. So diese Alternativlos-Scheiße, nach der wir auch den Podcast benannt haben. So, da möchte ich gern wegbauen. Ich hätte jetzt hier gern so ein paar, so was können wir denn jetzt mal tun? Wir haben zehn Experten gefragt, hier sind Ihre Vorschläge. So, das hätte ich gern mal.
Ja, ich meine, die interessante Frage ist ja dann, wie viel halten die Menschen eigentlich aus? Also, weil so, den meisten geht ja dieser Lockdown und dieses eingesperrt sein und ihre Freunde nicht treffen können. Und so ja schon ganz schön auf den Keks. Und man merkt ja so gerade bei jüngeren Leuten, dass es dann da auch irgendwie so eine Trotzreaktion gibt oder so, ist sowas eigentlich erforscht?
Ja, das nennt man, also psychologisch nennt man dieses Phänomen Reaktanz. Und das ist im Grunde so eine Art Abwehrreaktion, wenn es halt Einschränkungen von außen gibt. Also in dem Fall halt das Verbot oder irgendwie so eine Einschränkung von der Freiheit, die auch vorher da war. Und genau, also so man könnte auch sagen trotz. Und das kann dann natürlich zu unterschiedlichen Handlungen führen, die dann halt irgendwie eintreten danach. Also so zum Beispiel, dass man jetzt erst recht rausgeht.
Oder jetzt erst recht seine Freundin trifft oder Partys feiert oder sowas.
Ja, genau, jetzt erst recht Corona-Party. Das ist natürlich sehr unterschiedlich, irgendwie von Person zu Person. Also jeder hatte auch ein bisschen so einen, naja, so den individuellen Lernerfahrungen nach, irgendwie so unterschiedliche Arten damit umzugehen. Es gibt Leute, die sind sehr schnell reagierend darauf. Andere Leute haben durch eine andere Biografie vielleicht eher gelernt, dass sie ohnehin nicht beeinflussen können, was passiert. Und fühlen sich dann eher hilflos dadurch. Also würden auch nicht rausgehen, sondern sagen, ah, ich kann eh nichts ändern, dann bleibe ich erst recht drin. Ich versuch's gar nicht erst.
Also quasi so eine nicht aktive Reaktanz oder so. Oder wie nennt man so was?
Na ja, es ist noch ein bisschen ein anderes Konzept. Also man könnte eher sagen, es ist wie so eine gelernte Hilflosigkeit. Also so was fast schon eher irgendwie in der Depression rangeht. Also so, dass man eigentlich so immer erfahren hat, ich kann nicht kontrollieren, was passiert draußen. Aber so ich erwarte auch gar nicht, dass ich das kontrollieren kann. So ich traue mir gar nicht zu, dass ich da Einfluss haben kann. Deshalb versuche ich es nicht. Ich bleib einfach drin und warte, was passiert.
Also was ja in diesem Fall jetzt ja gerade zumindest die epidemiologisch gewünschte Verhaltensweise wäre.
Ja genau. Ich glaube also so, man kann das natürlich erleichtern. Also so Reaktanz tritt natürlich ein, wenn man auch nicht so wirklich versteht, was passiert. Oder wenn man es irgendwie nicht nachvollziehen kann oder es nicht sinnvoll findet. Das heißt, je besser irgendwie erklärt ist, wieso bestimmte Maßnahmen notwendig sind, umso mehr können Menschen da auch mitgehen. Also das ist so ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, weil niemand möchte irgendwie willkürliche Einschränkungen von seiner Freiheit akzeptieren.
Aber das heißt ja, dass den Leuten erklären, was jetzt passiert und warum man es macht, was ja gerade passiert jetzt mal irgendwie mit so ein paar Schwankungen so, also was jetzt zum Beispiel das ganze Thema Masken benutzen oder nicht Masken benutzen, würde ich ja eher so ein bisschen unter Kommunikationsfehler verbuchen seitens der Regierung. Aber ansonsten wird das schon erstaunlich stark versucht, zu erklären und Wissenschaftler in den Vordergrund zu schieben, um genau dieses Verständnis zu wecken und die Leute dazu zu bringen, aus Einsicht in Notwendigkeit zu handeln oder wie siehst du das?
Doch, ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich glaube, man muss schon, man muss sehr gut im Verdrängen sein, um das jetzt nicht verstanden zu haben, was natürlich trotzdem irgendwie emotional nicht bedeuten muss, dass man es irgendwie, dass man es gut findet. Natürlich nicht. Und typisch für Reaktanz ist zum Beispiel auch, dass man so die Handlungsoption, die im Moment nicht möglich ist, gleichzeitig aufwertet, weil es eben gerade nicht geht. So ein anderes Beispiel, also man könnte da zum Beispiel sich auch den Klopapierverkauf angucken. Je knapper Klopapier zu sein scheint, umso begehrenswärter ist es auch. Selbst wenn Menschen irgendwie noch drei Packungen zu Hause haben, je mehr sie davon überzeugt sind, dass dieses Gut knapp ist, je mehr sie Angst haben, oh, ich werde nicht mehr die Freiheit haben, welches zu kaufen, umso eher fangen sie an zu hamstern.
Ja, nun kann man natürlich irgendwie Bewegungsfreiheit schlecht hamstern.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber ich glaube schon, dass es auch diesen Effekt gibt. Also ich merke das ja auch bei mir so. Wenn ich, also dieses irgendwie tatsächlich rausgehen, mich bewegen, irgendwie das so ein Ding, was ich mir auch nehme, irgendwie so als das Gefühl von, auch wenn ich jetzt eigentlich wüsste, vielleicht wäre es besser, weniger rauszugehen, aber irgendwie geht es gar nicht anders, als es doch zu machen. Also irgendwie den Versuch zu unternehmen, mich irgendwie doch noch irgendwie frei zu fühlen, sei es halt nur irgendwie zum Kaffee zu fahren, ein Stück Kuchen zu kaufen, uns dann irgendwo im Park zu essen oder so, einfach nur um irgendwie so eine gewisse Normalitätsfreiheitssimulation, sogar Ad-Extrakt irgendwie noch zu haben.
Ja, ich glaube, dass das so ein Grund ist und dass es auch so ganz wichtig ist, dass es noch so bestimmte Spielräume auch in so einer Auslegung von Regeln gibt. Also so die aktuelle neue Regel ist ja, dass man schon nicht notwendige Wege vermeiden soll, aber dass so sportliche Betätigung oder Bewegung irgendwie erlaubt ist. Wir haben aber noch nicht den Stand, wie es zum Beispiel in Frankreich ist, dass man sich wirklich nur in einem sehr eng begrenzten Radius um die eigene Wohnung bewegen darf und auch nur eine bestimmte Zeit. Ich glaube, da können wir noch eigentlich ganz glücklich sein, um dieses kleine Freiheitsgefühl irgendwie noch haben zu können und uns eben irgendwie in der frischen Luft bewegen zu können. Und gleichzeitig natürlich darauf zu achten, dass wir irgendwie bestimmte Regeln halt nicht brechen und irgendwie eben nicht in der großen Gruppe unterwegs sind.
Wie würdest du das jetzt so aus professioneller Sicht beurteilen, die Kommunikation und die Regeln? Machen die das eigentlich ganz okay so oder?
Tja, gute Frage, das hängt ja auch ein bisschen davon ab, was man so für ein Menschenbild hat und was man so den Mitmenschen zutraut. Tendenziell finde ich es persönlich schon besser, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass Menschen erst mal nichts Böses wollen und dass Menschen auch erst mal so ein Grundverständnis davon entwickeln können, was wichtig ist und sich dementsprechend verhalten können. Es hat sich natürlich gezeigt, dass es trotzdem Corona-Partys gab, etc., woraufhin die notwendigen Maßnahmen verschärft worden sind und auch klarer kommuniziert worden sind. Ich finde, manchmal gibt es schon so kleine Unschärfen oder Inkonsistenzen, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel verschiedene Bundesländer vergleicht. Das finde ich schwierig, dass in dem einen Land irgendwie das erlaubt ist, in dem anderen Land aber nicht. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig, kognitiv nachzuvollziehen einfach. Ich finde, es wird ein bisschen schwierig, wenn es so in diese Bußgeldgeschichten geht. Wieso kostet was wie viel? Wieso muss hier der Ausweis mitgenommen werden und dort nicht? Das hinterlässt dann halt irgendwie so einen Beigeschmack von Willkür. Auch wenn man das Gefühl hat, ja gut, da hat sich jemand was bei gedacht, dass es so besser funktioniert, weil bei uns die Leute halt irgendwie auf diese Signale reagieren. Weiß ich nicht. Auch das ist ja irgendwie gerade so ein Level von, na ja, fast so einem riesigen sozialen Experiment irgendwie, wie wir das auch in unterschiedlichen Staaten unterschiedlich gehandhabt wird. Und wahrscheinlich werden wir dann irgendwann sehen, was am besten funktioniert hat.
Ich glaube, dieses, was wir insgesamt als Gesellschaft tun können, da sind wir auch an so einem Experten-Deadlock. Das sehen wir jetzt gerade halt irgendwie so an dieser Frage mit den Masken. Also eigentlich ist sowohl intuitiv als auch irgendwie wissenschaftlich vollkommen klar, das Richtige wäre jetzt, wenn wir rausgehen, mindestens wenn wir irgendwo sind, wo andere Menschen sind oder mal waren, also zum Beispiel Supermarkt, dass die Maske aufsetzen irgendwie das Richtige wäre. Und dann gibt es aber so dieses taktische Spielchen, das jetzt nicht zu sagen, weil wir halt nicht genug ordentliche Masken gebunkert haben, damit unser medizinisches Personal die kriegen kann. Und anstatt jetzt zu sagen so klare Ansage, wir brauchen alle Masken, näht euch selber welche oder wickelt euch einen Schal um den Mund, auf jeden Fall habt ihr irgendwas um den Mund und die Nase, damit irgendwie die Viruslast wenigstens um die Hälfte reduziert wird, falls ihr irgendwie in eine Wolke lauft, kommt jetzt irgendwie so eine Rumgeeiere mit Ja, und es hilft ja dann doch nicht so richtig und so, was halt nicht Stand der Wissenschaft ist. Also Stand der Wissenschaft, wenn man die japanische Studien anguckt, ist halt ganz klar, wenn da 80 Prozent der Leute Masken aufhaben und sei es nur einfache Stoffmasken, dann wissen wir zumindest von Grippeepidemien, dass die halt signifikant schwächer verlaufen.
Das ist seit spätestens Jahrhundert bekannt, dass es bei Corona auch so ist. Das ist jetzt keine neue Erkenntnis. Das ärgert mich auch sehr. Aber diese Taktikgeschichte, ich habe den Eindruck, das ist sogar schlechter als im Kalten Krieg. Da haben wir so Duck- und Cover-Bullshit gehabt. Aber immerhin, ja. Und heute erzählt man uns Sachen lieber aus taktischen Gründen gar nicht, weil das könnte irgendwie nach hinten losgehen.
Ja, oder erzeugt halt irgendwie so einen sozialen Druck, also ich meine, wenn ich heute mit einer Maske in den Supermarkt gehe, die halt nicht nach irgendwie handgeklöppelter Stoffmaske aussieht, weil ich halt irgendwie einen Stapel davon rumliegen habe, dann gucken mich die Leute halt einfach böse an oder feinden mich sogar an, weil von wegen ich würde doch irgendjemand hier die Maske wegnehmen. So und ich meine und dabei habe ich heute halt eine Maske aufgesetzt, weil da draußen halt einfach gerade Polenalarm ist.
Und weil Frank ein Trepper ist und Masken im Bucke hat schon seit 20 Jahren.
Klar, so, natürlich, klar. Aber ich finde halt auch dieses, was mich gerade wirklich sehr anfrisst, ist auch so dieses, dass diese Blockwart-Mentalität jetzt so hochkommt in den Leuten. Also dass die sich halt in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern verpetzen, die halt ihre Nachbarn, nur weil die halt dann nur in Zweitwohnsitz keinen Erstwohnsitz haben. Irgendwie so hier wirst du auf der Straße irgendwie entweder komisch angeguckt oder so angegiftet, wenn du eine Maske auf hast, so was total vernünftig ist, die aufzuhaben, genauso wie es total vernünftig ist, irgendwie auf seinen Wochenende auszufahren, um einfach weniger Leute aber in den Garten hat. Aber das sind halt so Sachen, wo dann diese offizielle Guidance als Entschuldigung benutzt wird, halt irgendwie seinen inneren Blockwart raushängen zu lassen. Und da frage ich mich dann so, also bei allem irgendwie Berichterstattung über Solidarität und das Schöne und das Gute und so, wie geht denn das eigentlich weiter? Also wo hören die Leute denn damit auf? Oder wird das jetzt immer nur noch schlimmer? Oder haben sie irgendwann noch die Schnauze vollfahren?
Ich glaube, die sind einfach verzweifelt alle und möchten gerne helfen. Und sie glauben, dass sie ja helfen, wenn sie dich anschwärzen, weil du einen Zweitwohnsitz hast. Also viele von den Leuten sind ja überzeugt davon, dass sie hier gerade das Richtige und Gute tun und Menschenleben retten, wenn sie dich anschwärzen, weil du eine Maske hast und das Krankenhaus hat keine. Also ich würde da keine Bösartigkeit vermuten. Ich glaube, das wird auch besser, wenn der Informationsstand besser wird. Aber wenn du anfängst, so taktische Überlegungen zu haben und den Leuten irgendwie nur eine vereinfachte Wahrheit zu sagen und denken, dann passiert sowas halt. Also da kann ich keinem böse sein. Das ist zwar alles tragisch, aber die haben ja nichts gegen dich, sondern die glauben halt, dass dein Verhalten scheiße ist, weil sie schlecht informiert sind. Und da können wir jetzt ja gegensteuern.
Und es tut wahrscheinlich im Moment auch einfach unglaublich gut, irgendetwas zu tun, weil es ja so dermaßen unintuitiv ist, einfach dadurch, dass man nichts tut und zu Hause ist und irgendwie sich nicht mit anderen austauscht, dass man dadurch eigentlich den größten Effekt schaffen kann. Also deshalb dann vielleicht auch so ein komischer Aktionismus.
Also du meinst, dass quasi so dieses Blockwartwesen ist dann halt eher die Suche nach Selbstwirksamkeit?
Auf eine Art schon.
Du, ich glaube, wir können den Leuten auch empfehlen, dass sie alle Nerds werden. Ja, weil mein Eindruck ist, dass die Nerds alle entspannt sind gerade, weil die das seit 20 Jahren genauso machen wie jetzt. Die sitzen halt zu Hause, haben Internet, tauschen sich da sozial aus. Das geht ja. Ja, man kann sich ja sozial austauschen. Die ganzen Leute, die jetzt zur Corona-Krise zum ersten Mal eine Videokonferenz mit ihren Eltern machen, die erleben natürlich so die Reibung am Anfang. Aber das kann man auch alles schon vorher aufgesetzt haben und dann flutscht das, außer das Internet ist lahm. Also dieses Gefühl, ich kann hier nichts tun, das betrifft mich zum Beispiel nicht. Ich habe hier gerade Dinge zu tun. Also sogar wenn man den Job günstig gewählt hat, kann man sogar einfach weiterarbeiten, weil Homeoffice halt geht als Option. Das betrifft jetzt gerade Nerds vermehrt, weil die halt IT-Jobs haben, wo man vielleicht nicht hinfahren muss, wenn man Glück hat, aber es ist ja nicht so, dass man gezwungen ist, zu Hause auf seinem Hintern zu sitzen und nichts zu tun. Ja, sondern man kann ja selbst jetzt irgendwie, also eine der Sachen, die mich wirklich positiv stimmt in den letzten Wochen ist, lauter Theater und Museen und Opern haben angefangen, ihren Content einfach kostenlos ins Netz zu tun. Bücher sind plötzlich verfügbar, also das Internetarchiv hat zum Beispiel Millionen von Büchern einfach online gestellt und wird jetzt von irgendwelchen Autoren angefeindet, deswegen so die Wiener Staatsoper war relativ früh dabei. Also es gibt überhaupt keine Ausrede dafür, zu Hause zu sitzen und sich zu langweilen. Es gibt tolle Sachen, die man gerade halt online...
Na Christiane, du bist ja da eigentlich auch noch Spezialistin für, also für dieses, was kann man denn eigentlich tun mit Spiel und mit Medien und sich mit sich verbinden, um irgendwie die Decke nicht auf den Kopf fallen zu lassen. Vielleicht kannst du da noch mal kurz was über erzählen.
Ja, das ist interessant, was die Theater gerade machen, weil das natürlich irgendwie ziemlich viele Sachen sind, die man sich einfach anguckt. Also es wird halt viel gestreamt und so. Ich finde das auch toll, dass es jetzt passiert. Auf eine Art finde ich aber, es hätte schon lange irgendwie so sein müssen, dass einfach von jeder Inszenierung irgendwie auch eine Abfilmung im Netz steht. Ich glaube, man muss irgendwie so ein bisschen gucken, wie man trotzdem gut miteinander in Verbindung bleiben kann, irgendwie auch über die Distanz. Und ich finde ja auch, dass ich da irgendwie, dass ich da Bildschirm und Intimität irgendwie nicht unbedingt widersprechen müssen oder dass man, dass man da nicht so auf Distanz sein muss eigentlich. Und ich habe zum Beispiel, ich glaube letzte Woche oder vorletzte Woche schon so eine kleine Seite gemacht mit so 42 verschiedenen Challenges drauf. Die man irgendwie alleine machen kann oder mit mehreren Leuten, mit denen man gerade die Wohnung teilt oder auch irgendwie Telepräsenz zusammen. Und das sind irgendwie, das sind so viele verschiedene, so ein bisschen manchmal lustige, manchmal ernste Sachen, was weiß ich, baut irgendwie zusammen eine Fast-Food-Skulptur aus der Wohnzimmereinrichtung oder irgendwie sortiert 20 Sachen nach irgendeinem Kriterium, Größe, Art, whatever. Also so Sachen, die einen irgendwie kurzzeitig ablenken, wo man aber trotzdem auch mal ein bisschen nachdenken muss.
Es gibt gerade eine Aktion vom Getty-Museum, ich weiß nicht, ob du das gesehen hast.
Die haben dazu aufgerufen, das ist das mit den Bildern, ne?
Genau, Bilder nachzustellen, so mit Haushalt-Items und haben halt so ein paar Testbilder so als Beispiel. Das fand ich total super.
Also mir ist aufgefallen, dass ich jemanden geschickt habe.
Ja, ich war absolut großartig. Also mein Eindruck ist, wenn man jetzt anfängt, nachdem alle zu Hause im Hauskoller sitzen, dann irgendwie zu chatten oder so, dann hat man nichts, worüber man reden kann, weil man nichts erlebt hat. Deswegen würde ich vorschlagen, vorher mal ein Buch zu lesen. Also jeder, der ich kenne, hat zu Hause mindestens fünf Bücher, die auf der Liste stehen, zu denen man nie kommt. Lest die doch mal oder guckt euch eine schöne Oper an und dann habt ihr was, worüber ihr reden könnt. Und das ist dann auch ein Gefühl, dass es auch erfüllend ist, wenn man das mit anderen teilen kann. Also aber jetzt einfach irgendwie in den Chat rumzuhängen.
Ich glaube, man muss halt ein bisschen aufpassen. Ich glaube, da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen, weil natürlich kann man jetzt auch noch irgendwie supergeil japanisch lernen und noch irgendwie eine Programmiersprache und alles. Ist auch, glaube ich, echt eine gute Zeit dafür. Nur glaube ich, dass man auch gerade vielleicht irgendwie manchmal mit anderen Sachen beschäftigt ist oder irgendwie nicht so super konzentriert ist, weil einfach irgendwie echt viel komisches Zeug in der Welt passiert. Und ich glaube, so ein bisschen muss man aufpassen, dass man sich nicht da über so ein Optimierungsgedanken dann anfängt zu definieren. Wobei der Range zwischen Buchlesen und Japanisch lernen noch größer ist.
Also ich meine jetzt nicht, du sollst sozusagen mit dem Ziel, was weiß ich, jetzt irgendwie lerne Englisch in drei Tagen Buchlesen, sondern mir ging es darum, lese ein bisschen in dem Buch, am besten kein Sachbuch, sondern Belletristik, damit du was hast, worüber du mit den sozialen Kontakten reden kannst. Denn wenn alle nur zu Hause sitzen und reden und da ist aber nichts passiert, dann ist man zusammen gelangweilt. Das stimmt auch niemandem.
Das stimmt.
Ja, also macht irgendwas, was die anderen noch nicht gemacht haben, und dann habt ihr was, worüber ihr reden könnt.
Quarantäne, dein Projekt mit den Challenges, machen die Leute das tatsächlich? Also tun die das Dinge?
Ja, die Leute machen das tatsächlich. Und ich kriege so mit, wie Leute das machen, weil sie mir dann irgendwelche Bilder schicken. Der größte Teil der Leute, die es machen, machen das nicht alleine. Und teilen sie es nicht bei Twitter. Wie ich am Anfang dachte, das wäre total cool, wenn dann alle da irgendwie ihre Bilder teilen. Ich habe zum Beispiel auch die Challenge irgendwie stellt ein berühmtes Gemälde nach mit Sachen aus eurer Wohnung. Aber das hat halt noch niemand gemacht. Aber es wird ziemlich viel in so privaten WhatsApp, Telegram, whatever Gruppen gespielt. Und da kriege ich dann immer wieder irgendwelche Bilder zugeschickt über den Kontakt, der da auf der Seite steht. Und freue mich dann immer.
Hat schon jemand eine Corona Skulptur gemacht?
Ja, das war eine der ersten Sachen, die gemacht worden ist. Die habe ich aber auch privat zugeschickt bekommen. Sie hat geleuchtet.
Okay.
Ja, also den Link werden wir halt auch in die Notes tun, damit ihr dann auch die Challenges machen könntest. Vielleicht sollten wir auch noch zusammen eine Alternativlos-Challenge ausdenken.
Na ja, das hätten wir vielleicht vorher besprechen.
Das sollte man aber. Ich finde, ich habe eine Idee. Ihr könntet das Alternativlos-Logo, was ihr auf der Webseite findet, mit Gegenständen beziehungsweise Personen aus eurem Haushalt nachstellen und uns davon ein Bild schicken.
Sehr schön.
Also ein wichtiger Hinweis dabei, die Krankenhäuser sind gerade relativ überlastet, also versucht euch dabei nicht zu verletzen. Das wäre, glaube ich, nicht so gut. Diese Frage von irgendwie, es passiert ja nichts, es ist ja auch so ein bisschen der Hintergrund von irgendwie, sich dann so ein bisschen leicht absurde Sachen vornehmen, dass man ein bisschen was zu lachen darüber hat oder beziehungsweise irgendwas macht, was man sonst nie machen würde, um sich dann darüber zu freuen, dass man sie gemacht hat. Wie lange hält denn sowas? Also wie lange können wir das denn jetzt noch so versuchen, so halbironisch zu betrachten? Also wann fängt es an, irgendwie leer zu laufen, so als Beschäftigungstherapie? Gibt es da irgendwie Erfahrungen zu?
Also ich kann das jetzt nicht sagen. Ich weiß nicht, was da so der kritische Zeitraum ist.
Es ist ja so eine gewisse Robinson Crusoe Situation eigentlich. Also man ist halt quasi auf so einer, also quasi wie Robinson Crusoe mit Telegraf oder mit Telefon. Man ist auf einer einsamen Insel, hat irgendwie alles, was in seiner Wohnung ist als Spielzeug und kann sich mit anderen darüber unterhalten, wie man seine Spiegel erinnert.
Ich glaube, eine wesentliche Veränderung wird es geben, wenn das Internet zusammenbricht.
Ich glaube, dann gehen die Leute einfach auf die Straße und ignorieren die Ausgangssperre.
Ja, dann haben wir hier Blut in den Straßen. Also ich habe neulich gelesen, da hat jemand empfohlen, diese Art von Sachen zu machen, nicht um sich abzulenken, also schon um sich abzulenken, aber halt nicht sozusagen, es geht nicht um die Aktion, die man da macht, sondern es geht darum, von dem Newsfeed wegzukommen, der sozusagen eine Abwärtsspirale bildet. Würdest du dem zustimmen, dass man den Newsfeed eigentlich lieber abbestellen und ignorieren sollte, weil der einen nur deprimiert wird?
Ich würde auch empfehlen, dass man so dieses typische sprunghafte Lesen vermeidet, also dass man immer dann doch noch ein Browserfenster offen hat und dann doch noch mal wieder die Karte mit den Zahlen aktualisiert, sondern vielleicht auch versucht, sich eh irgendwie den Tag ein bisschen zu strukturieren, also egal wie das aussieht. Also heute habe ich zum Beispiel diese Infografik gesehen, dass so sich die Duschzeiten der Berliner nach hinten verschoben haben, sowohl in der Woche als auch am Wochenende, dass durchschnittlich jetzt viel später geduscht wird.
Von den Wasserwerken oder wie?
Ja genau.
Die schlafen wahrscheinlich auch einfach.
Es wird jetzt länger geschlafen, also so signifikant spätere Duschen. Das ist jetzt irgendwie so die Homeoffice-Begleiterscheinung. Aber ich glaube trotzdem, dass es wichtig ist, irgendwie so für sich selbst so einen bestimmten Rhythmus zu finden. Und es ist ja cool, wenn er nicht mehr so extrem von außen bestimmt sein muss. Aber wenn man nicht durchdrehen will, hilft das, glaube ich, wenn man klarere Zeiten hat, in denen man sich dann auch Nachrichten anguckt und den Rest der Zeit versucht, irgendwie mit anderen Sachen zu füllen. Und da kann man sich zum Beispiel auch so bestimmte Zeitstrukturierungstools irgendwie zu Hilfe nehmen, was weiß ich, so wie wenn man so High Intensity Intervall Training macht, wo man irgendwie so einen bestimmten Zeitraum Sport macht und dann eine Erholungsphase hat. Das kann man ja irgendwie auch auf den Rest des Lebens übertragen oder Pomodoro als Arbeitstechnik oder ähnliches, dass man halt weiß, in dieser Zeit mache ich jetzt das und danach mache ich wieder was anderes. So das kann halt so eine Struktur schaffen, wo sonst viele Strukturen gerade weggebrochen sind.
Ich meine, das ist ja so ein Ding, was auch die ganzen Astronauten und Expeditionsteilnehmer und so gerade, die jetzt ja gefragt werden, wie hält man das dann durch, die sagen ja auch alle, dass der Schlüssel, um irgendwie durchzuhalten in so Situationen der Abgeschlossenheit oder des eingeschränkten sozialen Kontakts halt irgendwie ein durchstrukturierter Tagesablauf ist, wo man halt dann eben auch nicht so viel drüber nachdenken muss, was man als Nächstes tut. Dazu sollte es da aber eigentlich auch schon Untersuchungen geben, oder?
Ja, das hilft auf jeden Fall. Und ich meine, es ist ja auch eine Sinnfrage, ne? Ich glaube, in dieser großen Situation, wo irgendwie alles unsicher ist, sieht es ja erstmal so aus, als ob es gerade gar keinen Sinn macht, Dinge zu tun. Und irgendwie stimmt es dann auch subjektiv gesehen. Es macht aber auch keinen Sinn, Dinge nicht zu tun. Und eigentlich, egal, um welche psychischen Probleme es geht, Struktur hilft meistens sehr. Es sei denn, es handelt sich um Zwangsstörungen. Und da soll es eher ein bisschen weniger Struktur sein, ne? Aber ansonsten ist es, glaube ich, total gut und richtig und wichtig, irgendwie auch für sich das richtige Ausmaß, an Struktur zu finden. Und damit kann man ja auch experimentieren. Und jetzt ist die Phase, wo man damit experimentieren kann. Also vielleicht hilft es auch einigen Leuten, einfach mehr auszuprobieren. Man könnte zum Beispiel auch irgendwie andere Schlafmodelle ausprobieren. Man muss ja nicht irgendwie einmal am Tag schlafen, sondern man kann auch ausprobieren, was weiß ich, das Modell, dass man alle vier Stunden eine Viertelstunde schläft oder so. Kann man alles machen, solange es einem dabei gut geht. Und solange man irgendwie einen Plan hat und sich zumindest so auf Sichtweite, für sich, in seinem Leben orientieren kann.
Ja, dieses mit dem, dass es einem gut geht. Was ich halt festgestellt habe, ist, dass man so ein bisschen den Track darüber verliert, wenn man sich keine Notizen macht. Das stimmt. Also, ich habe halt irgendwie gerade relativ viel quergelesen von so alten Expeditionsberichten. Ein Ding, was die alle immer machen, ist Tagebuch. Expeditionstagebuch, auch wenn sie nur reinschreiben, irgendwie heute haben wir vier Konservendosen aufgemacht und eine Eisscholle beiseite geschoben. Selbst dann gab es irgendeine Art von Zeit-Flock. Was ich gerade festgestellt habe, seit ich angefangen habe, mir jeden Tag kurze Notizen zu machen, was so war und wie es mir ging, hat das Leben wieder mehr Struktur als so ein Huch, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich für einen Wochentag? Keine Ahnung. Wie lange ist denn jetzt eigentlich schon dieser Zustandding, was vorher so ein bisschen so das Problem war?
Ja, das hilft auf jeden Fall. Ich habe zum Beispiel mit mehreren befreundeten Autoren und Autorinnen, wir haben so ein gemeinsames Dokument, wo wir quasi ein gemeinsames Tagebuch reinschreiben. Also jeder für sich. Und wir leben in verschiedenen Städten und können irgendwie auch sehen, was die anderen so machen und so. Also es hilft, glaube ich, alles so, jede Art, sich Notizen zu machen, weil das halt so ein Anker in der Realität ist.
Also ich kann ja Block führen empfehlen. Ich würde aber aus eigener Beobachtung sagen, mir fällt eigentlich nie auf, wenn es gerade gut geht, sondern es fällt nur auf, wenn es nicht gut geht. Also das finde ich ein bisschen schwierig, sozusagen, mach Sachen nur, wenn es dir gut geht. Oder mach nur weiter, wenn es dir gut geht. Erst mal gibt es zwar ja eine gewisse Latenz. Also selbst mal, man macht jetzt irgendwie, man geht jeden Morgen in den Park und macht da irgendwie Sportübungen oder so. Da hast du ja auch erst mal zwei Tage Muskelkater oder so, bevor es besser geht. So, das finde ich einen schwierigen Rat. Und zu merken, dass es einem besser geht, als vorher, ist gar nicht so einfach, weil die Sinne eigentlich eher das Gegenteil kommunizieren. Wenn es einem scheiße geht, dann merkt man das. Und wenn es aufhört oder langsam weniger wird, das merkt man auch nicht direkt, sondern nur, wenn man ein Tagebuch führt oder so.
Das stimmt.
Ich würde auch gerne auf diesen Selbstoptimierung, irgendwie Selbsthilfe, ich sage mal, das amerikanische Modell zurückkommen nochmal, was vorhin so ein bisschen zur Seite geschoben hat. Aber das ist ja eigentlich, ich kann, ich höre total häufig Leute sagen, das und das wollte ich eigentlich schon immer mal machen, aber ich habe ja keine Zeit. So und jetzt haben sie alle Zeit, aber es macht irgendwie keiner die Dinge, die da immer liegen geblieben sind. Das wundert mich so ein bisschen. Ich würde das ja auch selbst nicht ausnehmen.
Nee, das kann ich finde ich völlig verständlich, weil mir geht es zum Beispiel so, dass meine Konzentrationsfähigkeit durch diesen ganzen Quatsch da draußen und diese Unsicherheit und dieses permanente Gefühl von Bedrohung massiv abnimmt. Also, so richtig in den Flow zu kommen und irgendwie Sachen hintereinander weggearbeitet zu bekommen, ist signifikant schwieriger, als es das vorher war. Also, selbst jetzt unter selben Zeitgesichtspunkten. Also, abgesehen davon ist ja die Arbeit nicht weg. Also, die findet ja nur anders statt. Und ich kann dem eigentlich auch nicht zustimmen, dass irgendwie so Homeoffice und Telearbeit weniger Arbeitszeit frisst. Im Gegenteil, also ist bei mir eigentlich eher mehr. Also, insofern...
Nee, das hat, glaube ich, auch keiner behauptet. Also, das wollte ich jedenfalls nicht behaupten.
Nee, aber ich glaube halt einfach, dieses Gefühl von jetzt ist ja die Zeit dafür, nur weil man halt zu Hause arbeitet. Hab ich halt überhaupt nicht. Also, wenn ich so auf meinen Tagesablauf gucke...
Ich glaube, wir beide sind da echt in einer privilegierten Situation. Also, viele andere Selbstständige haben gerade total Ausfall und hängen irgendwie den Tag lang in Warteschleifen rum beim Senat auf irgendwelche beschissenen Webseiten, um sich da für irgendwelche Hilfen einzutragen. Und denen fällt die Decke auf den Kopf. Ja, also ich habe hier auch noch Dinge zu tun, aber ich glaube, das ist nicht der Normalfall. Insofern glaube ich schon, dass es im Moment viele Leute gibt, die so ein bisschen denen die Decke auf den Kopf hält und die eigentlich eine Liste hätten, die sie schon immer mal machen wollten. Und denen würde ich gerne zurufen, probiert es einfach mal, denn das Gefühl, was geschafft zu haben, ist für mich jedenfalls immer eins der höchsten Glücksgefühle, die man so haben kann, mit relativ wenig Aufwand. Also ich habe mich jetzt hingesetzt und das kam vorhin so ein bisschen als Joke und habe gedacht, okay, ich lerne jetzt mal eine neue Programmiersprache. Ja, das dauert natürlich länger. Ich habe jetzt auch noch nicht viel gemacht. Und mir geht das ja auch so, dass ich abgelenkt werde. Aber das Problem habe ich ja ansonsten auch. Also das würde ich jetzt nicht als neu einschätzen. Es geht mir sonst genauso. Also wenn ich Internet an habe und da irgendwelcher Scheiß rein scrollt, dass ich dann ablenkbar bin, da muss man jetzt wie sonst auch gegen ankämpfen. Aber das Gefühl, ich habe jetzt was erreicht, das kann man mit so einfachen Mitteln haben. Also bei uns im Moment ist es so, dass die Mülltonne unten immer voll ist, weil die Leute alle ihre Wohnung aufräumen, als wenn es kein Morgen gäbe. Und das kann auch helfen. Einfach das Gefühl, ich habe jetzt hier mal einen Sack rausgetragen, jetzt ist es besser als vorher. Das ist ein gutes Gefühl. Das kann ich allen nur empfehlen. Macht irgendwas. Es muss keinen Sinn haben. Aber das Gefühl, ich habe jetzt was erreicht, ich habe jetzt was gemacht und ich kann jetzt auf irgendwas zeigen, was besser ist als vorher, das solltet ihr anstreben. Lasst euch da nicht ins Boxhorn jagen von Gefühlen, der irgendwie, ihr könnt ihr nichts machen oder so. Probiert es einfach aus, lest irgendwelche Bücher, guckt euch einen Stream von einer Oper an. Kunst, ja, also das ist eine der Sachen, ich bin ja kein Freund von Merkel eigentlich, aber das ist eine Sache, die ich im Moment sehr positiv, auch im Vergleich zur Reaktion von anderen Ländern wahrgenommen habe, dass bei uns tatsächlich angesagt wurde, das Überleben der Kunst, gerade in Zeiten wie jetzt, wichtig. Deswegen machen wir einen Topf auf für die Künstler. Das hat mich stolz gemacht. Ich bin selten stolz auf mein Land, aber das hat mich stolz gemacht. Und das sollten wir dann auch nutzen, wenn die Kunst auf der Straße liegt.
Nutzt das.
Ich glaube, dem kann man jetzt nicht mehr viel hinzufügen. Das ist ja extrem gut. Ich glaube, das wäre auch mein Fazit, dass was machen natürlich immer besser ist als nichts machen. Ich glaube, dieser Mangel an Selbstwirksamkeit kommt ja vor allen Dingen, dass man das Gefühl hat, man muss selbst an der gesellschaftlichen Situation etwas ändern und kann es im Moment irgendwie nicht. Dass natürlich jeder für sich in privaten Dinge lernen kann oder irgendwie coole Sachen machen kann, klar. Man kann zum Beispiel, wenn man nichts anderes findet und sich noch mal auf eine andere Art mit viralen Krankheiten beschäftigen möchte, kann man zum Beispiel auch Plague Inc. spielen, wo man nämlich selbst ein Virus spielt, der die Menschheit ausrotten möchte. Ja, ja, ja, also so, es ist 2012 rausgekommen, das boomt total durch Corona. Es wurde Ende Februar in China verboten. Und das ist natürlich jetzt nichts, was irgendwie wissenschaftlich super korrekt irgendwie gebaut worden ist. Allerdings ist das seit 2012 auch irgendwie mehrmals nachgebessert worden. Und es gibt zum Beispiel da so ein Impfgegner Szenario auch drin, die sich positiv auf die Verbreitung auswirken. Also auch sowas kann natürlich sein, womit man wieder so eine Agency zurückgewinnt, dass man einfach mal so im Spiel die Perspektive wechselt und sich irgendwie diese Mechanismen noch mal anders anguckt. Also es ist auf jeden Fall in der Beliebtheit gestiegen und sehr, sehr oft runtergeladen worden.
Ist auch ein gutes Spiel. Also ist ein gutes Spiel. Und das ist auch nicht unwissenschaftlich. Die Leute haben sich zusammengesetzt mit dem Typ, der die CDC beraten hat, das ist die amerikanische Katastrophen-Viren-Ausbruch-Bekämpfungsbehörde. Ja, das hat schon Hand und Fuß, was dir da also nicht völlig ist. Immer noch ein Spiel. Aber das wäre gut gewesen, wenn die Leute das vor der Pandemie gespielt hätten. Denn da, die Hauptlektion in dem Spiel ist nämlich, dass wenn du sagst, irgendwie mein Erreger ist sofort tödlich und hat eine kleine Inkubationszeit, dann wirst du nie gewinnen. Ja, weil das Virus läuft sich sofort tot. Die gewinnen den Viren, also das Szenario in dem Spiel ist, man muss die ganze Welt infizieren und man selbst spielt den Erreger. Das heißt, das Gewinde, also das tödlichste Pathogen, was man bauen kann, ist eins, was möglichst wenig Symptome hat. Am Anfang noch keine negativen Symptome, sondern die kommen erst später durch Mutationen rein. So und die Tödlichkeitsschwelle ist gering, aber die Ansteckungsrate ist hoch. Und das ist genau die Kombination, die wir jetzt beim Coronavirus haben. Das heißt, als ich das Coronavirus gesehen habe, habe ich sozusagen auf meine Erfahrung mit Plague Inc. zurückgreifen können und wusste, okay, das ist jetzt ein Problem. Das jetzt anzufangen zu spielen, ist, glaube ich, zu spät. Aber es könnte natürlich trotzdem machen, so als Spaß am Gerät. Aber eigentlich wäre es gut gewesen, wenn die Lektion vorher angekommen wäre, finde ich.
Na, es gibt ja durchaus eine Erweiterung jetzt. Und ich weiß nicht, ob die schon da sind. Falls hatten sie angekündigt, wo man Defense spielen kann. Also wo man sagt, okay, man probiert jetzt verschiedene Methoden aus, mit was man irgendwie gegen so Pandemien tun kann. Also mit Lockdown und so weiter und so fort. Ich weiß nicht, ob die schon draußen sind. Müssen wir nochmal nachgucken, aber um genau dieses Agency-Ding halt irgendwie zu bekommen.
Naja, ich wäre vorsichtig damit, den Anspruch sozusagen zu befeuern, dass etwas, was ich jetzt tue, der Welt helfen muss. Ich glaube, es ist hilfreicher zu sagen, es muss erst mal mir selbst helfen oder gar keinem. Das reicht schon. Hauptsache, ich tue was.
Ich glaube, über das Spiel spielen würde man das gar nicht denken. Aber vielleicht könnte das helfen, dass man überhaupt die Zusammenhänge versteht oder ein bisschen besser nachvollziehen kann, welche Maßnahmen überhaupt welche konkreten Auswirkungen haben, wenn man es dann irgendwie visualisiert hat.
Auch immer geht es auf Wikipedia-Versuch.
Jetzt kriegen wir gerade noch einen zweiten Studio-Gast dazu, nämlich den Rob. Wir sind gerade mit der Sendung an dem Punkt, wo wir darüber diskutiert haben, was man so tun kann, um Selbstwirksamkeit zu haben. Wir haben hier noch Christiane Hütter in der Sendung, die sich mit zum einen Psychologie von Großschadensereignissen beschäftigt hat und zum anderen so Dinge macht, mit denen man versuchen kann, nicht total durchzudrehen. Die Sachen, die du machst, sind ja eher gerade so ein bisschen mehr konkreter.
Ich tue, was ich kann, ja.
Na, erzähl doch mal, du machst gerade Covid at Home, heißt das Projekt?
Das Projekt heißt Covid at Home und hat eigentlich angefangen damit, dass Vera, meine Frau und ich, angefangen haben, für Freunde und Bekannte unsere Recherchen ein bisschen zusammenzufassen. Wir waren dann schon tagelang am Suchen, was ist dann diese Krankheit, dieses Covid-19, was ist dann das, was macht das alles? Was soll man dann tun, wenn man es hat? Weil wir fanden ziemlich viel Information, wie man es vorbeugt, wie man dafür sorgt, dass man es nicht kriegt. Aber wir wollten eigentlich so ein bisschen wissen, was passiert dann, wenn man es doch hat. Ja, da waren wir dann so drei, vier, fünf Tage, dann war es eine Woche. Das würde immer mehr. Ja, also wir haben das auf einer Webseite getan. Und dann haben wir festgestellt, dass immer mehr Leute diese Webseite dann weitergegeben haben. Und dann gab es auch Ärzte, die das toll fanden und auch Kommentar hatten und teilweise auch Kritik. Das sollte die wirklich anders formulieren oder das werden die Leute falsch verstehen. Und daraus wird eigentlich so ein komplettes System. Es wird quasi ein User Manual für Covid. Ja, es hat alles angefangen. Als Katastrophenprophet ist man ja zuerst das Arbeitslos.
Nur weil wir eine Katastrophe haben, weiß das nicht, dass nicht noch mehr kommen wird.
Ja, genau. Aber trotzdem, meine Rolle ist immer so ein bisschen pessimistischer zu sein als die anderen. Und wenn alle dann so pessimistisch sein, dann habe ich eher das Gefühl, positiv sein zu wollen. Ich weiß nicht, immer dagegen.
Hey, das hättest du uns früher sagen müssen, dann wären wir schon früher immer total negativ gewesen.
Ich bin immer mit so, ich mag es, Sachen mal richtig durch zu recherchieren und dann aufzuschreiben, was Quatsch ist und was nicht. So ein bisschen Sinn und Unsinn trennen. Und Fera mag das auch. Und sie ist auch lebenslanger Pop-Met-Nurse. Sie liest richtig viel Studien aus dem medizinischen Bereich und kennt sich so ein bisschen aus da. Ja, und so haben wir das dann angefangen.
Und wir hatten gerade vorhin das Thema, dass diese Ungewissheit und dieser Informationsmangel die Leute halt irgendwie marode macht. Habt ihr denn das Gefühl, dass da, also dass es irgendwie hilft? Also dass die Menschen sich mit so ein bisschen mehr klare Informationen irgendwie besser fühlen?
Ja, ich kann eigentlich nur beurteilen, dass es uns wirklich gut hilft. Also Vera und mich, aber auch alle Freiwilligen, die mitgeholfen haben, die Leute, die wir treffen uns täglich und wir arbeiten dran und wir machen die die Informationen auf der Seite immer besser, wird immer besser formuliert. Also uns hilft es auf jeden Fall hervorragend. Und die Leute, die sehen, haben das Gefühl, dass die Information auch richtig viel bringt. Wir versuchen ehrlich zu sein. Wir versuchen alles eigentlich gut zu besprechen und nicht irgendwie zu viel drum herum zu reden. Der Ton ist der Ton gefällt richtig viele Leute.
Das ist auch richtig viel Material. Also wenn man das jetzt ausdruckt, kommen so weiß ich nicht 50 Seiten oder so raus. Das ist eine Menge Holz und das sind aber alles so kurze Bullet Points. Ja schön aufgegliedert nach du wohnst in der WG. Ja was kannst du tun oder du bist allein zu hause. Was kannst du tun? Das ist schon eine gute Ressource.
Ja, es hat alles damit angefangen, dass wir diese Zahlen zu uns genommen haben. Und dass so von der Leute die Symptome bekommen, dass die bei 80 Prozent mild to moderate sind. Und wir hatten mal so eine Lungenentzündung. Und dann haben wir festgestellt, das hat überhaupt keinen Spaß gemacht. So mild to moderate Lungenentzündung haben, kann schon ziemlich heftig sein. Und da kann man schon eine Menge machen, um sich darauf vorzubereiten, dass das passieren könnte und was man dann vielleicht tun könnte und so.
Du hatte irgendwie vor einer Woche auch so zehn Tage lang halt irgendwie keine Ahnung irgendwas, so irgendwie, ob es jetzt Pointe-Chitis war oder Covid, weiß keiner. Also was mich halt irgendwie so ein bisschen angefressen hat, war halt irgendwie, dass es irgendwie nicht so richtig eine gute Beschäftigung gibt, außer Filme gucken. Macht ihr da auch irgendwie Hinweise für, was man so tun kann, wenn man irgendwie so halb neben der Tasse ist?
Ja, wir haben eine ganze Liste mit so Sachen, die mit psychisches Wohlbefinden zu tun haben. Da steht eine ganze Menge darauf. Die Ursprung dieser Liste ist übrigens komisch, hat angefangen mit einer Liste, die von der österreichischen Armee erstellt worden ist, von deren psychologischen Dienst.
Ah, genau, die haben ja auch einen Blog gehabt, ich erinnere mich.
Aber ist ein bisschen kompakter gemacht und besser formuliert hier und da. Aber die Liste hat schon Sinn gemacht, was da alles drauf war.
Christiane, bist du noch bei uns?
Ja, ich bin noch da.
Ah, du bist noch da, alles klar. Wie siehst du das so, sich irgendwie so head-on mit dem Problem beschäftigen und mit der Krankheit und irgendwie dem möglichen Unwohlsein, was damit zusammenkommen kann? Ist das irgendwie psychologisch günstig oder sollte man es nur machen, wenn man irgendwie sowieso schon eher in so einem Doomsday-Modus und das dann eher so der das Bright Light ist?
Es ist wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen Persönlichkeitssache, aber ich glaube, wenn, ich glaube, Informationen können eigentlich nicht schaden, wenn sie sinnvoll sind und besonders, wenn man irgendwie auch Lust hat, sich in Studien einzulesen und sich damit irgendwie sicherer und vorbereitet fühlt, kann man ja nichts Besseres machen. Und dann noch die Informationen dann für andere bereitstellen, damit die dann direkt ein bisschen kondensierter lesen können, ist ja total cool.
Ich würde auch gerne noch einen Kommentar kurz sagen. Also es gab eine Wortmeldung von der deutschen Gesellschaft für, wie war denn das, Depressionshilfe, deutsche Depressionshilfe, so hießen die. Und die haben gesagt, die Situation sei besonders schlecht gerade für Leute, die eh mit Depressionen zu Hause rumliegen. Und ich glaube, das betrifft mehr als bei denen, das diagnostiziert ist. Und ich würde allen empfehlen, aus eigener Erfahrung, tut Dinge, bei denen ihr das Gefühl habt, es hilft anderen. Das ist einer der besten Motivatoren, die es gibt. Und so Material sammeln über Covid kann das zum Beispiel auch erfüllen. Wenn es Leute gibt, die das lesen und wenn die euch dann eine Mail schreiben, so das hat mir geholfen, das ist sehr viel wert. Wenn ihr jetzt schon überlegt, was ihr gerade tun könnt, um euch die Decke nicht auf den Kopf fällt, dann würde ich vorschlagen, nehmt euch was, was auch anderen hilft. Und wenn ihr eine Ressource gerade benutzt, die irgendein Typ ins Internet gestellt hat, dann schreibt ihn auch mal eine Mail, so das hat mir jetzt geholfen. Das ist so eine Sache, die kostet keinen was und die hilft so viel. Macht das. Versucht anderen zu helfen. Und wenn andere euch helfen, dann seid dankbar.
Und ob die Seite jetzt zum unteren auf Englisch und auch noch auf Deutsch oder wie ist jetzt da der Status?
Die Seite ist jetzt auf Spanisch oben.
Ja, die ganze Seite.
Nee, sechs. Waren das eins, zwei, drei, sechs?
Ja, die Seite ist in ziemlich viele Sprachen übersetzt. Hab ich hier eine Liste. Deutsch, Spanisch, Italienisch, Holländisch, Polnisch und Rumänisch und Französisch ist auch noch in der Arbeit. Also eine Menge Sprachen.
Okay. Braucht ihr da noch Hilfe oder ist alles gut? Oder seid ihr jetzt langsam fertig damit?
Wir können immer Hilfe gebrauchen. Die Übersetzungen sind jetzt, weil wir der letzte Woche ziemlich viel gearbeitet haben, die Übersetzungen sind jetzt drei, vier Tage in der Zeit zurück. Wir arbeiten jetzt sehr kräftig daran, dass Deutsch schnell besser ist. Aber auch die anderen Sprachen sollten in so drei, vier Tagen deutlich viel besser sein, als sie jetzt sind. Aber Englisch ist auf der heutigen Stand.
Okay, cool. Und du meinst Feedback von den Medizinern ist eher positiv? Also die freuen sich darüber, dass sie weniger Leute in den Krankenhäusern kriegen?
Ja, wir sind auf Twitter erwähnt worden von einer Professorin, die die Hausärzte ausbildet. Und die war total begeistert. Ja, total toll, sollten alle sehen. Guckt euch das an. Und deswegen sind wir jetzt in der UK viel gelesen, vor allem auch von Ärzten. Wir haben auch Hilfe bekommen von einem Arzt, der selber eine Firma hat und die machen medizinische Informationsverbreitung. Die machen auch Apps und so. Und da hat sich das alles durchgelesen und da kamen richtig viele gute Vorschläge, wie man das verbessern könnte. Also ja, vor allem in der UK werden wir jetzt langsam groß.
Ja, ich glaube, dass das nicht nur inhaltlich, sondern auch psychologisch wichtig die Liste, die du da gemacht hast, weil die geht nicht nur für, wie kann ich jetzt vorbeugen, sondern die geht. Stufe zwei ist, okay, ich habe Symptome. Stufe drei ist, mir geht es scheiße. Stufe vier ist, Experten müssen sich kümmern. Das heißt, wenn ich vorher diesen Ablauf gesehen habe, kann ich da ganz anders hingehen. Dann ist so ein Großteil von dem, von der ich weiß gar nicht, was jetzt kommt, Angst ist dann weg. Also allein dafür finde ich das schon hilfreich. Selbst wenn es mich gar nicht betrifft, kann ich einfach so das Gefühl haben, okay, ich bin jetzt ein Schritt voraus der Sache. Das ist jetzt nichts mehr, was aus dem Dunkeln kommt und mich unerwartet erwischt, sondern ich habe so ein bisschen eine Ahnung, wo es hingehen kann.
Ja, und gerade weil wir keine Ärzte sind, sind wir da auch so ein bisschen naiv rangegangen. Wir haben nur uns informieren wollen, was passiert dann und was, und weil man hat da so ein paar Bilanzen, die so ein bisschen schwierig sind. An der einen Seite gibt es The Worried Well. Das ist kein Brunnen, sondern das sind die Leute, die ins Krankenhaus gehen oder zum Arzt gehen, wenn sie eigentlich noch ganz in Ordnung sind. An der anderen Seite gibt es diese Ausdruckung aufs Englischen A little knowledge is a dangerous thing. Man möchte eigentlich die Leute ein bisschen Vertrauen geben, wenn es um Krankenpflege, auch wenn es um Selbstkrankenpflege geht, dass sie nicht gleich in Panik sich versetzen, wenn sie mal Fieber haben oder mal... Aber gleichzeitig will man auch nicht, dass die Leute das Gefühl haben, dass sie kein Medical Advice mehr brauchen. Wir können natürlich nur informieren. Wir können nur Informationen verbreiten. Wir sind keine Ärzte und wir geben auch ausdrücklich keinen Medical Advice. Aber da bilanziert es. Sonst gibt es noch mehr von solchen Sachen. Man muss Sachen so erzählen, dass sie schon stimmen, aber auch nicht zu viel deprimieren, wenn es nur eine kleine Menge von Leuten betrifft, bei denen es schlimmer wird. Es gibt so viele Sachen, wo man so ein bisschen hin und her bilanziert. Am Anfang haben wir den Fehler gemacht, dass wir versucht haben, lokale Informationen, dass wir lokale und zeitkritische Informationen da reingesteckt haben. Das ist natürlich nicht zu pflegen, schon für ein Land nicht. Auch wenn man es tut, dann ist die Information, die man online findet, auch manchmal nichts mit der Situation on the ground zu tun. Es kann sein, dass im Internet, dass du findest, dass Tests bei Hotline bla beantragt werden können und Hotline ist nicht erreichbar. Also wir haben alles, was an Lokal- oder Contemporary-Information drin war, haben wir rausgestrippt und dann nur weiße Textboxes reingetan, mit hier brauchst du Lokal-Information, hier musst du dich mal informieren, was jetzt Sache ist bei dir. Weil das wird sich auch im Laufe der Krise noch verändern. Es wird zum Beispiel welche Leute getestet werden oder was passiert mit Leuten, die es schon gehabt haben. Demnächst wird es auch Antibody-Tests geben, dass wir auch so wissen, wer schon immun ist, hoffentlich. Also allerhand Sachen werden sich ändern und auch Sachen ändern sich, wo man ist und auch wie die Sache da gerade ist. Und wir sagen also, das brauchst du jetzt an lokale Information, aber der Rest bleibt eigentlich gleich. Also wir sind eher ergänzend. Und seit wir das machen, haben wir uns besser fokussiert. Ist das seit auch deutlich besser geworden? Weil das war nicht handhabbar. Da hätten wir dann ein international Covid-News-Gathering-NGO werden müssen, das wäre dann auch wieder ein bisschen heftig.
Ja, verstehe. Ja, weil du gerade Antibody-Tests sagtest, also das Versprechen ist ja dann so ein bisschen, endlich Gewissheit zu haben, weil diese PCR-Tests sind ja offensichtlich nicht besonders zuverlässig, weil halt irgendwie die Frage, wann man sie genau nimmt und wie halt der Abstrich genau funktioniert und so, hat ja doch so gewisse Unwerkbarkeiten. Und so ein Antikörpertest verspricht ja dann quasi, so eine irgendeine Form von Gewissheit.
Ja, das müssen wir alles noch abwarten. Also, da, der Research ist immer noch ongoing, was da, inwiefern gibt es Dauerimmunität? Es gibt ja mehrere ganz komische Zwischenfälle. Es gibt Leute, die negativ testen und dann wieder positiv. Und da sind die Wissenschefler sich auch noch nicht ganz einig, was da jetzt genau los ist. Und wie genau denn die Antibody-Tests sein werden? Und die werden auch noch besser werden? Und ob man die selber zu Hause machen kann? Es sieht aus, als ob das funktionieren könnte, auf jeden Fall.
Aber wir wissen es halt noch nicht.
Wir wissen es halt noch nicht.
Ich würde gerne die Formulierung noch mal korrigieren. Frank meinte gerade, der Test sei unzuverlässig. Das würde ich so nicht stehen lassen wollen. Der Test ist schon zuverlässig, aber er misst nicht das, was man hoffen würde, was er misst. Der Test erkennt schon zuverlässig, wenn der Virus da ist. Und er kennt auch nicht andere Viren, die man haben kann, fälschlich als Corona-Virus. Das ist nicht die Art von Unzuverlässigkeit, die Frank gerade meinte.
Die Amerikaner hatten eine lange Zeit unzuverlässige Tests. Ich glaube, die ersten zwei Wochen. Weil das CDC da an Vorkarren hatte.
Es ist ja, dass Leute, die offensichtlich krank waren oder sind, halt negative PCR-Tests haben, weil entweder halt der Test zu spät genommen wurde oder halt nicht doll genug mit dem Stäbchen gedrückt wurde. So was halt so die wahrscheinlich Problemphänomene sind, die halt so auftreten. Also insofern.
Na oder weil dein Immunsystem die Viren weggeräumt hat.
Ja, wir werden noch so viel über dieses Virus lernen.
Wir hatten ja vorhin so die Diskussion genau um diese diese Unzuverlässigkeit der Informationslage, die Ungewissheit von dem, was da noch an Zukunft kommt. Und ich hab halt so ein bisschen Sorge, dass es halt irgendwie zu so einem Phänomen kommen wird, dass wir immer wieder glauben, jetzt hätten wir ja so ein kleines Stück Gewissheit, was dann aber halt leider doch komplett wegbröselt. Und dass es die Leute halt noch mehr mürbe macht, wenn sie dann glauben, jetzt wäre wieder irgendwas, was man zumindest mal glauben könnte. Und dann ist es doch wieder irgendwie nur Quicksand. Irgendwie hilft uns nicht so richtig weiter.
Zu Leute, die zu mir sowas sagen, sag ich, welcome to my world.
Ich mein, nee, aber ich würde an der Stelle nochmal dafür warnen, wollen sich in so einfache Erklärungen hineinzusteigern, was ich gerade ein bisschen beobachte. Ich kriege immer noch Mails so, ja, dieser Virus ist ja alles ein Hoax, das ist ja erfunden, das ist bloß eine Grippe. Und das führt dazu, mal ganz unabhängig vom Wahrheitsgehalt, diese Aussagen, führt das dazu, dass man sich selbst das letzte bisschen Agency wegnimmt. Ja, weil man sagt, dunkle Mächte kontrollieren das alles. Und dann kann man ja erst recht nichts mehr machen. Ja, das heißt, die eigene Lage wird durch dieses Weltbild noch verschärft. Allein aus dem Gesichtspunkt heraus würde ich schon dringend davor abraten, jetzt hier irgendwelche Weltuntergangsgeschichten. Also eine Sache, die zum Beispiel gerade kursiert ist so, das Finanzsystem kollabiert gerade und der Covid-Scheiß ist nur vorgeschoben, damit sie hier nochmal alle das Geld raustragen können. So diese Art von Verschwörungstheorie hat gerade Hochkonjunktur. Ja und das führt einfach zu rein negativen Auswirkungen für euch selber, wenn ihr das glaubt. Selbst wenn da was dran ist und wenn da nichts dran ist, ist sowieso egal. Insofern versucht euch mal selbst, in die Richtung zu optimieren, dass ihr so ein bisschen Hoffnung noch offen lasst. Allein aus dem Selbsterhaltungstrieb heraus, weil das hat ja keinen Wert. Selbst wenn es dunkle Mächte gibt, die uns alle platt machen wollen, dann brauchen wir auch morgendwann jemanden, der sich gekämpft kann. Ja, also macht euch mal nicht jetzt platt.
Apropos Hoffnung, man könnte sogar sagen, es könnte gut sein, dass Historiker in 40, 50, 60 Jahren feststellen, dass es alles viel schlimmer gelaufen wäre, wenn der Menschheit nicht in 2020 von diesem Virus überzeugt wurde, dass es notwendig war, alle gemeinsam Leben zu ändern, um Katastrophe zu vermeiden, weil das brauchen wir gerade auch für Klimawandel und Artensterben ganz dringend, dass wir alle unser Leben dramatisch ändern, damit wir die Katastrophe vermeiden. Die Katastrophe ist nur ein bisschen langsamer, aber es ist schon etwas Wichtiges, was wir jetzt alles lernen. Und es werden ziemlich viele unterschiedliche Policies geben, es werden sehr viele unterschiedliche lokale outcomes geben, wie das alles jetzt ausgeht. Und da werden wir unhändlich viel davon lernen. Und das sind Sachen, die wir auch dringend lernen müssen. Also so könnte man sehen, vielleicht ist das genau, was wir gebraucht haben, stellen wir in 50 Jahren fest. Ist natürlich jetzt immer noch ein paar Jahre Scheiße.
Na, das kann man noch jetzt schon feststellen. Also in China konnte man das relativ deutlich sehen. Die haben ja noch die letzten Grippe mutierten Halbangst-Pandemien erlebt. Die Vogelgrippe, die dann nicht so schlimm war. Und die auch bei uns immer gerne in Verschwörungstheorien genannt wird, warum diese Grippe dann auch nicht schlimm ist. Aber das haben die Chinesen live erlebt. Und das ist der Grund, warum die jetzt überhaupt vorbereitet genug waren, um in Wuhan Lockdown zu machen. Also schon jetzt ist es so, man muss gar nicht irgendwie nebulös in die Zukunft gucken. Schon jetzt kann man sagen, ab und zu mal so eine Pandemieübung rettet Menschenleben in der nächsten Pandemie. Und das kommt, ist klar.
Na gut, also sozusagen zu sagen, es ist ja nicht alles aussichtslos und möglicherweise ist das, was wir jetzt gerade brauchten als Menschheit so ein gewisser Wachrüttler, um irgendwie es mit diesem Planeten nicht komplett zu versemmeln, ist natürlich irgendwie.
Das ist ein super Antifragilitätstraining.
Hey, wir haben endlich saubere Luft.
Na ja, also es ist ja nicht wirklich Training, sondern das ist ja sozusagen eher eine, mehr so ein Brute-Forcing von allen fragilen Dingen, die wir gerade so aufgebaut haben.
Aber einen Punkt haben wir noch. Wir wollten noch darauf eingehen, so Mitmachoptionen, Bastelkram, was man so... Also es gibt gerade viele Leute, die überlegen, kann man nicht mit einem 3D-Drucker helfen oder kann man nicht Atemmasken selber machen. Wir haben schon eine Atemmaske erwähnt. Da muss man aber vorsichtig sein. Und ich glaube, das ist sinnvoll, wenn wir das hier mal ansprechen. Es gibt nämlich gerade so Abmahn-Anwälte, die dann im Netz rumlaufen, wenn man dann versucht, seine Sachen an den Mann zu bringen, selbst wenn man die verschenkt. Und da schreibt man dann so geschützte Kategoriennamen ran, oder man behauptet, es sei ein medizinisches Gerät. Da kriegt man dann ganz schnell eine Abmahnung. Also nur, weil ihr das gut meint und weil ihr verschenkt, heißt das nicht, dass das harmlos ist. Da müsst ihr euch vorher gut informieren. Du hast doch dann Übersicht, Frank. Was darf man nicht sagen? Atemmaske darf man glaube ich nicht sagen, oder?
Nee, alles, wo Schutz drin ist, darf man angeblich nicht sagen, wobei ich das bisher auch nur aus zweiter Hand gesehen und noch nicht selber verifiziert habe. Ich bin im Übrigen dafür, dass man diese Abmahnanwälte an den Pranger stellt. Das heißt also, wenn ihr solche Abmahnung bekommt, postet bitte mit Kanzlei und Namen in den sozialen Medien. Wir müssen da tatsächlich konstatiert gegen vorgehen, weil es ist irgendwie nicht einzusehen, dass diese Leute aus reiner Profitgier tatsächlich jetzt gerade medizinisch notwendigen Maßnahmen im Wege stehen und dem Schutz der Bevölkerung vor einer Infektionskrankheit im Wege stehen. Und ich bin da durchaus der Meinung, dass man da irgendwie im Zweifel auch das Infektionsschutzgesetz irgendwie in Anschlag bringen muss, um sicherzustellen, dass diesen Leuten das Handwerk gelegt wird.
Wie viel verbrannte Erde haben die schon länger verdient, wenn du mich fragst?
Ja, also wenn wir irgendwie im Rahmen von dieser Corona-Geschichte am Ende dieses Abmahn-Anwalts unwesend loswerden, dann kann man sagen, okay, dann würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, hat sich das gelohnt, aber das ist zumindest ein positiver Punkt.
Schon wieder was geschafft.
Genau, wieder was geschafft. Nee, also tatsächlich, da bin ich wirklich an dem Punkt so, auf gar keinen Fall dulden, im Zweifel gleich direkt öffentlich machen und irgendwie beim Justizministerium melden wegen Abmahn-Missbrauch, weil das kann einfach schlicht und ergreifend nicht sein, dass Leute versuchen jetzt zu helfen und dann dafür eine Abmahnung kassieren. Also da habe ich sowas von kein Verständnis für, da fehlen mir die Worte.
Also inhaltlich haben wir vorhin schon gesagt, sage ich jetzt nochmal, der Stand der Wissenschaft ist eine auch selbst gebastelte, auch irgendwie aus rumblickenden Komponenten, sowas wie Kaffeefilter oder Teefilter oder was weiß ich. Staubsaugerbeutel. Genau, Staubsaugerbeutel, gebastelte Masken, auch die haben einen positiven Effekt. Das ist zwar nicht 100%, aber wenn ihr die tragt, verhindert ihr schon mal zuverlässig, dass ihr andere infiziert. Das ist die halbe Miete. Wenn das viele Leute machen wie in Asien, dann sinkt die Rate der Neuinfektionen drastisch. Das heißt, es sieht auch gerade so aus, als wenn demnächst in einigen Bundesländern oder vielleicht sogar bundesweit eine Pflicht zu Atemmasken verhängt wird, dann werden sie die wahrscheinlich in Supermärkten ausgeben und es ist eh egal. Aber bis dahin ist das keine schlechte Idee, selber sich eine Maske zu basteln und die zu tragen.
Genau, man sollte halt auf zwei Dinge achten. Zum einen, man sollte davon ausgehen, dass die Außenseite nach dem Tragen infektiös ist. Das heißt also, mit Handschuhen arbeiten. Zum anderen sollte man darauf achten, dass man die möglichst nicht zu lange trägt und wäscht. Weil das Problem ist, dass sich da natürlich auch andere Dinge drin sammeln können. Man will halt nicht eine Maske, die schon so versifft ist, dass man sich dann da andere Keime mit reinzieht, während man versucht, sich vor Corona zu schützen. Das heißt, im Zweifel die Maske waschen oder man kann sie auch bei so was wie so 70 Grad ungefähr in den Backofen tun oder im Zweifel auch einfach mit dem Föhn behandeln, während man eine andere Maske trägt, um nicht die aufgeholten Partikel einzuatmen. Also Backofen ist besser, um halt Virenpartikel und sonstiges Zeug zu inaktivieren. Das ist halt eine, muss man mal ein bisschen im Netz lesen, es gibt da so einiges an Hinweisen dazu. Also immer dran denken, so nicht nur irgendwie Cargokult betreiben und zu sagen, man hat jetzt eine Maske und jetzt bin ich sicher, sondern einfach wissen, okay Maske ist nur ein Bestandteil in der sonstigen Desinfektionshygiene und man muss damit sinnvoll umgehen. Also ganz wichtig. Und nicht glauben, dass irgendwie eine Textilmaske wirklich hilft, wenn ihr irgendwie Corona-infizierte Patienten behandeln müsst. Aber das macht glaube ich vom medizinischen Personal auch tatsächlich niemand.
Für euch, damit ihr andere nicht ansteckt.
Genau.
Oder das könnt ihr eurem Nachbarn schenken, damit er euch nicht ansteckt.
Ja, das ist auch sehr sinnvoll.
Und ihr habt was getan, wenn ihr so eine Maske gebastelt habt.
Und man kann tatsächlich seine Maske selber gestalten. Das finde ich auch wichtig. Nicht nur so eine blöde, grüne oder blaue oder weiße Maske, sondern man kann die irgendwie natürlich aus dem rumliegenden, hässlichen Stoff, den man noch nie verwenden wollte, sich eine schöne Maske bauen.
So eine 50er-Jahre-Blümchen-Tapete. Oder so eine Cosplay-Geschichte. Das geht natürlich auch.
Oder so a la Hirschbeutel. Hirschbeutel? Hirschbeutel ist so richtig früher gab es so Wandbehänge, auf denen war häufiger ein röhrender Hirsch. Die erste Generation von so Hippies, die dann das mit der Ironie in der Mode erfunden hat.
Ich muss mal kurz Wikipedia vorlesen, warte mal. Der Hirschbeutel oder auch Pennerbeutel. Pennerbeutel ist eine selbst gelete Umhänge-Tasche. Alles klar. Mit einem dekorativen Wanteppich. Oh, mit einem sehr schönes Bild haben sie auf Wikipedia.
Genau, weil es halt diese Wandbehänge gab, wo ein Röhre der Hirsch drauf war. Daraus haben die Leute sich dann halt um ihre Taschen genäht.
Oh Gott, das ist stilicher bis zuletzt. Also wer damit Corona kriegt, hat nachgewiesen, dass das Virus keine Standards hat. Also, liebe Hörer, bleibt gesund. Macht schöne Dinge mit eurer Zeit. Hält anderen. Bedankt euch.
Genau, und wenn ihr spenden wollt, dann spendet nicht uns, sondern spendet Leute, die sie wirklich brauchen. Sei es irgendwie kleine Läden in eurer Nachbarschaft oder zum Beispiel eure Lieblingspartyveranstalter, Lieblingsclubs, die irgendwie gerade echt am knabbern sind. Alle Business, die irgendwie Publikum brauchen, um zu existieren, haben gerade echt eine harte Zeit.
Ja, auch die, die kein Publikum kriegen, das kann ich gleich kurz erzählen. Ich habe ja neulich irgendwie in einem Seitensatz einen Nebensatz erwähnt, so ja, Glühbirnen kriegt man ja nicht mehr, nach dem Motto. Weil in Ulm ein Supermarkt aus irgendwelchen Regulierungsgründen alle Nicht-Essens-Waren abgedeckt hatte. Ja, so und dann schrieb mir ein Elektriker, so ja, sie würden ja gerne kommen und eine Glühbirne mitbringen. So die, die Elektriker sind ja auch kleine Unternehmen und die sitzen auch alle auf dem Trockenen. Also das sind nicht nur die, die Publikumsverkehr haben, im Sinne von da kommt jemand vorbei. Das sind auch so, weiß ich nicht, die Klempner und Elektriker der Republik, die haben auch alle gerade Not. Das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt eh zu Hause seid gerade und irgendwas eh repariert werden musste, ist das auch eine gute Gelegenheit, da das einfach mal vorzuziehen und jetzt zu machen.
Genau.
Wir müssen jetzt zusammenhalten.
Ja, aber trotzdem noch mal kurz, ich also eine Sache, die ich gerade noch pluggen muss, ist irgendwie so einer unserer Lieblingspartyveranstalter in Berlin. Der kann auch gerade dringend Hilfe gebrauchen, weil wir müssen auch nach der Solcher noch irgendwie in der Lage sein zu feiern, nämlich die Pyronen. Den werden wir auch noch in die Show links tun. Also wenn ihr irgendwie spenden wollt, wären die auf jeden Fall eine gute Idee. Die haben uns so viele gute Zeit bereitet, dass wir irgendwie denen auch gerne helfen würden, über diese schlechte Zeit zu kommen. Genau. Ansonsten die Quarantale-Challenges von Christiane. Da freuen wir uns auch darüber, wenn ihr lustige Bilder macht, zum Beispiel die Alternativlos-Challenge, die Bonus-Challenge oder was ist eigentlich dein Lieblings-Challenge, Christiane?
Meine Lieblings-Challenge ist, glaube ich, eine Remote-Band über ein beliebiges Videokonferenztool machen und eventuell auch einen Song aufnehmen.
Oh ja, das klingt doch wie eine super Idee.
Das funktioniert auch. Es gab Leute, die einen virtuellen Chor gemacht haben über sowas. Also das geht. Das klingt vielleicht absurd, aber es funktioniert. Und da kommen auch richtig geile Sachen raus. Das probiert man, wenn ihr musikalisch irgendwie nicht ganz...
Genau.
Und auch sonst, Playback geht auch, also...
Ja, den Link zu den Challenges und zu Quarantäne tun wir natürlich unten rein. Genau wie den Link zu Covid at Home, damit ihr euch vorbereiten könnt, falls es euch doch erwischt. Was gibt es sonst noch zu sagen? Vielen Dank fürs Mitmachen an alle Gäste und Gästinnen.
Jetzt hoffen wir mal, dass wir das Audio hier schön rausgekloppt kriegen aus den Tools, was wir hier benutzt haben.
Das wird auch für uns noch nicht so standardumgebung. Ja, dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bleibt gesund und bis zum nächsten Mal. Vielen Dank.